foreign
good morning welcome to the special
committee on housing
um we have a full day of presentations
today and uh these are some that I put
together from my contacts I think
they're going to be very informative and
helpful and
um
for planning purposes I just want to let
the committee know that we're planning
on another full day of presentations on
April 14th so to mark your calendars for
that that's two weeks from today
um
representative
okay
thank you for letting me know
okay thank you
all right so um we'll stand by I'll try
to book it for another week thank you
for letting me know ahead of time yep I
would love for not half the committee to
miss the presentation so you're welcome
okay
uh if there isn't anything else I want
to welcome up the murkadis Institute
from George Mason University
um Charles Gardner Salim Firth thank you
for coming
um I know we've been in contact for a
couple years regarding solutions to the
housing crisis in New Hampshire but I
think you guys can give us a great
overview of what's going on in other
states and some of the potential things
that we can be doing over here in New
Hampshire so thank you for coming
boom there we go
uh really pleased to be here
um
Mr chairman and representatives thank
you so much for your time I I'm
impressed that you're going to spend the
whole day longer than us
um talking about these things so please
be part of that we'll try to be useful
to you
um feel free to jump in anywhere uh
raise questions you know push back on us
if uh we've gotten something wrong about
New Hampshire we want this to be a
two-way conversation and
um we're just going to begin by
introducing uh ourselves so we are both
Scholars at the mercatus center at
George Mason University uh Mercedes is a
university-based research center where
non-partisan non-profit
we do not Lobby and we work with
legislators such as yourselves
not all 50 states but a lot of States we
work with federal policy makers and
locals as well as other academics and
people interested in housing issues
mercatus covers a range of issues Beyond
Urban economics and housing so we've got
colleagues who are working on drone
policy monetary policy lots of different
kind of Niche areas I would say within
economics broadly
um
my name is Celine Firth so I'm I'm the
one of the directors of the urbanity
project which is the urban economics and
housing group at Mercedes
um and I've been there since 2018. I got
my PhD at the University of Rochester
and got to retrain as an urban Economist
which is a lot more fun than being a
macro economist
um I'll let Charlie introduce himself
and then then we'll jump right into
presentations
uh good morning chairman and
representatives again thank you also for
for having us here this morning my name
is Charlie Gardner I'm a research fellow
with mercadis my background is as an
attorney in private practice until
joining mercantis just a little earlier
this year but um I got my undergraduate
degree actually from from Dartmouth
College just up the road so it's nice to
be back in New Hampshire uh uh after
some time and um
look forward to
presenting some information to you and
hopefully taking any questions that you
may have so thank you again
so we've we've given you a folder and I
hope you you know uh get to read this
you know just some references that we'll
have to stuff in the folder while we're
talking and then it's going to be more
reading for later so aside from our bios
I put together a little
um some basic stats on New Hampshire and
some policies that we're looking at in
other states I'll talk about that
handout a little bit
um there's testimony that I gave just
written testimony on
um
hb44 two months ago
on the right hand side of the folder is
the housing reform of the state's menu
of options these are
policies they're not relevant to every
single state but things that we thought
were broadly relevant to State
legislatures coming into this
legislative session and policy ideas
that we've seen work or that we would
like to see you know a state really try
and then my colleague Emily Hamilton
and one of our research assistants just
published a New Hampshire case study on
Accessory dwelling units and kind of
looked at a 2017 law that is fairly weak
but requires
towns to allow accessory dwelling units
there's lots of regulations that towns
can have but what she found was that
there's actually quite a substantial
rate of Permitting given the uh given
the level of the
stringencies that the law allows
so just going into like the some of the
stats first
um you know obviously you guys are here
because prices and rents are rising in
the state and you know just to sort of
satisfy all of us make sure we're almost
on the same page you know put together
um just a graph of what's happened to
prices in uh three the three largest
counties in New Hampshire
in the past what is this
seven years and you know you can see
there's a there's a strong upward trend
up into the beginning of the pandemic
and then it just absolutely takes off
you know the
the key here for me as an economist is
to look at prices and rents together
so if you see prices rising without
rents increasing
you might sort of suspect that demand is
coming from something
that's not fundamental right so it might
be just low interest rates it might be
Wall Street
investors chasing returns wherever they
can get them
but instead when you see rent and prices
rising together
this is basically going back to the
fundamentals right people don't rent
housing speculatively right rent is
always I just want a place to live it's
on a one-year basis
I'm paying for this because I want to
live here right now and when prices are
tracking that what it tells me is that
the demand is fundamental the demand is
human it's based in people's jobs
people's retirement incomes where people
want to live right now not something
speculative and I think that's important
when we talk about solutions that we
can't sort of
um you know play some magic trick or
push Wall Street out or
get interest rates right and make the
price problem disappear when it's based
in rents it's fundamental
um
so it gets really important evidence
now New Hampshire's housing stock in
this this is where the map comes in and
you can you know hopefully maybe find
your own District on here uh the space
the the blocks your census tracts which
is how the data arrives which is not
doesn't cleanly map to towns but usually
the census tracts follow Town borders
and as you can see there's actually a
pretty big decline in housing stock in
the North Country
um that's a big part of the map it's not
not a big part of the population of New
Hampshire and then downstate or most of
your districts are there's been a decent
increase in the housing stock but if you
look Statewide
New Hampshire's housing stock and New
Hampshire's population are growing at
about two-thirds of the national rate
and that's for the the kind of most of a
decade coming into
the the pandemic obviously thinks since
the pandemic things have been scrambled
and I'd say that probably the pandemic
accelerated that growing demand growth
um and that's going to look really
different in the different parts of the
state right so downstate
um long commutes are a lot more
tolerable when you only have to do them
a couple times a week you know or or
maybe once or twice a month even so
folks who
you know have a downtown Boston job if
they've only got to go there
you know once a week
an hour and a half commute or a long bus
ride in from from Nashville is not so
bad
um and so you're gonna see I think
durable Demand right that part-time work
is is going to stay with us so this
isn't just going to be a pandemic effect
it's gonna be more more demand for
living at the very edges of Metro areas
which the Boston metro area absolutely
gets into a lot of your districts
and then Upstate in the you know in The
Lakes area
um on the mountains
there you're seeing I think a different
demand that that's beyond most commuters
reach
but there's some small number of work
from anywhere people that's more likely
to be a pandemic effect that goes away
you know some people who were maybe
summer folks could spend all year there
in 2020 and 2021 maybe that's over for
them
um longer term there's a big gonna be a
big boom of retirements just based on
the U.S demographics the Baby Boomers
are all hitting retirement
and so that's that's a source of demand
that's long-term
um and it's not a lot of people but then
if you're you know a town like Meredith
it doesn't take a lot of retirees from
New York to be a lot of people in
Meredith
and so you can sort of get big
percentage increases from a relatively
small population which puts pressure on
a quite small housing stock that you get
in a a rural or a vacation oriented area
there's also more people like myself who
can take kind of long vacations
um and be away from their offices
working remotely for a long time and so
you can get increased demand for
uh places to nice places to become
vacation homes so somebody could say oh
I'm gonna go spend all of July you know
uh up in Ossipee instead of in DC and
skip that horrible DC weather but you
know work most of those days and so
that's going to be an increase in demand
so there's a bunch of sources
um that rent data is telling me it's
fundamental
and I I don't think we can you can
weight the problem out or hope that
higher interest rates uh solve it in the
long term so I'm going to hand it over
to Charlie and then
um
come back at the end and talk more about
solutions that other states are seeing
and that we're we've identified in our
menu of options
so just for a little bit of um review
and background on uh land use sort of
the legal perspective obviously land use
plannings existed for as long as there
have been cities but zoning in the
United States only only dates back about
a century and was approved by the
Supreme Court in 1926.
um so compared to the history of
history the country in particular
history of New Hampshire going back to
the 1600s a relatively a relatively
recent development
obviously New Hampshire as you know it's
a setting of the uh the case which
set in motion modern corporate law on
the free enterprise system the Dartmouth
versus Woodward case I just I think just
passed its 200th anniversary
um and that's some that's a tradition as
you know that's continued to the present
New Hampshire it's continually
uh rank near the top for uh or to the
close to the top among the 50 states for
economic freedom
now New Hampshire went approximately
300 years I believe the first settlement
New Hampshire was 1623 to the 1920s
without zoning so the historic
towns and cities that
we all know
in love in New Hampshire from Portsmouth
Wolfeboro were all developed and planned
out and built before zoning
today however at least the best estimate
I can find is the 220 out of New
Hampshire's 234 municipalities have
adopted zoning codes
now
New Hampshire's towns are
have derived their authority to Zone
from the state from from the state
enabling statute which is uh New
Hampshire revised Statute section 672-1
which has been amended a few times in
recent years
um
now that's the the current version of
that statute which you may be very
familiar with I don't know simply
provides that zoning should continue to
be the responsibility of municipalities
but also imposes some obligations upon
them including developing developing a
balanced supply of housing for people of
all incomes that's an obligation it's
actually placed on municipalities
promotion of Agriculture and Forestry
it's protecting those natural resources
from development for other uses
there's also a Prohibition on forbidding
in-home daycares not sure exactly when
that was adopted but setting a limit on
what local municipalities can do in
terms of restricting in-home businesses
again consistent with economic freedom
so New Hampshire has through those
changes to the enabling statute and
through certain other regulation has
acknowledged that there's a role for the
state in setting objectives for and
limitations on that local zoning power
uh both to promote individual property
rights to promote individual economic
freedom for example what you can use
what sort of businesses you can run out
of your own house
um which get down I think to the very
fundamentals of starting small
businesses and um
private Enterprise
so
there is uh there is certainly a
precedent for the state pushing back on
some of the most exclusionary and
restrictive rules that are set
um by by local towns and cities and
Celine will tell you just in a moment
how how some other states are
approaching these same issues and some
of the reforms
than other states have been looking as a
way to
return rights back to individual
Property Owners where municipalities
have
have interfered in a way that affects
property rights or economic freedom
so
um
in practice for example for here in
Concord the current zoning
heavily regulates existing areas close
to downtown where land values are
relatively High
whereas undeveloped areas
are
generally not treated with the the same
degree of attention
and there's been a development that's
occurred in
farmland and Forest land
so primarily
it is
sort of it is restricting opportunities
for redevelopment and growth in areas
where the highest demand for it exists
whereas being indifferent to growth on
the periphery which I think is resulted
in some of the development patterns
we've seen over the last 50 years
so
again I would just emphasize that I do
think there is a role here and there's
certainly president in New Hampshire and
from other states in the legislature
taking a taking an active role in
pushing back against some of the
constraints on housing production and
some of the constraints on people's
economic activities that you see at
local levels and I'll turn it back to
slim to give you a little more detail on
what's going on elsewhere but thank you
thank you Charlie
um so I talked in the sort of data
opening a little bit about supply and
demand so the demand is real it's
fundamental uh turning to the supply
side right ultimately
uh as policy makers you look at a market
um you can just sort of stand back and
say like okay we see supply and demand
prices move uh as supply and demand move
and we're not going to touch it like
that's just the market working and fine
um or you can come in and say okay well
we're going to affect the demand side
somehow like we might try to
interest rates to lower demand or we
might give people first time home buyer
credits or rental vouchers to boost
demand which can help individuals But
ultimately that flows into prices so
when
when you give first-time homebuyers a
credit then the people they're competing
against have to pay more to bid for the
same home so it has a distributional
effect maybe you like getting first-time
buyers into houses as opposed to letting
people move up or something else
But ultimately the
you know the net effect to the economy
is just you've got more money chasing
the same stock of houses
so when we're looking at this market now
you know our
interpretation as economists and and
lawyers is this isn't just a market you
should stand back from and say like okay
well this is just the world working and
sometimes things get more expensive like
eggs lately right the chickens got sick
so eggs are more expensive okay there's
not a lot we can do about that
um
but in this case the government has
played a very active role in determining
Supply
right so we created zoning 100 plus
years ago
and we delegated that power to
localities and they use zoning not just
to kind of make a place for everything
and keep noxious uses away from
residential uses uh which I don't know
anybody who who objects to
but to really curate the way that towns
grow this is true across the country uh
New Hampshire is unique in having a you
know the New England Town form of
government which we'll talk about in a
moment
but it's not unique in having a locally
based regulations that are decided by
usually very small numbers of people who
show up to hearings or who vote in local
elections and who take an active
interest in
the zoning that's that's often very
immediately in their neighborhood and so
you certainly understand those interests
and why people get involved but we can't
kind of look away from the fact that
the supply side of the housing market is
very much a government-led phenomenon
which means that the you know Solutions
are going to have to involve not be
solely governmental but have to involve
government thinking about its role
so you know I I as an I'm a
Massachusetts native so you know my
hometown had a militia and a welfare
state for a hundred years before the
American Revolution happened right I
take Town history and town government
really seriously
uh the New England town government is a
um one of the greatest
examples of and and examples for
American democracy as its practice
um people who know me as a scholar know
that I get I get really really angry
when people quote that tocqueville like
Township like New England Township thing
like there's no townships right
townships are the uninhabited areas and
this happened because tocqueville wrote
in French and then his translator was an
Englishman who'd never been to America
and so tocqueville visited American
towns it was a plaque right out there
um he wrote about commune in French and
that got translated back into English as
Township by somebody who had no idea
what he was talking about and this
entire branch of tocqueville scholarship
has gone on talking about Township
governments as if they couldn't just
like show up in a New Hampshire town
on a random Tuesday and see town
government in action and learn that it's
actually called Town um so you've got
all these people in their Ivory Tower
who have never been to a town meeting
and um don't know what to call it
I get very worked up about that
um
that said
town government shouldn't do everything
and you know even even with that history
of having its own Army and its own uh
welfare state
this doesn't mean that unlimited
unlimited power uh uh to regulate the
tax to spend is a good feature of town
democracy and I think that zoning as
we've given it to towns has actually
weakened that democracy
by making towns much more interested in
trying to curate what goes on inside
them via land use regulation rather than
trying to
Serve and Protect
what the citizens are doing as they they
spontaneously transform their living
patterns their business patterns their
land use patterns right so when you've
got a fundamentally fundamentally
exclusionary
um government right whether that's a
nation that says oh we're going to have
no immigrants and we're just gonna like
you know we're for the natives and we
don't want anybody else here and we
don't want to change right that becomes
a negative government it's just trying
to stop things from happening
and I think the town government can be
incredibly powerful incredibly useful
but it shouldn't be in the role of
saying who gets to be here and what gets
to be here it can do things like
um guiding and creating public
Investments right you can't do Urban
growth without streets sewers Parks
schools that's all the role of
government
and town government is an incredibly
powerful tool and an incredibly useful
one for letting citizens kind of
directly affect an impact
the way that growth happens and sort of
being the handmaiden and following what
people in their private lives are doing
thank you so much Josh
um
but uh
zoning power shouldn't be unlimited that
also doesn't mean that zoning power
should go to the state um
I think you know you see sort of
I see people in maybe in California and
Oregon merging this way a little bit
that like well we can't trust the cities
and the towns so let's just basically
move the zoning power to the statement
although we're still going to have
zoning power we're still gonna have all
these little rules that decide what can
go where and I think that's a terrible
idea please don't
um I don't think there's any any
appetite for that New Hampshire happily
but I think there's three there's three
Arguments for State preemption
um where preemption means not taking
over zoning but putting guard rails on
what towns can do and streamlining their
process
I'm going to leave you in suspense
uh for just a moment
so the first argument for State
preemption is property rights
so any regulation or delegation of
regulatory Authority
um by a government to a government
should face the burden of proof right so
we
going back to the chickens and the eggs
like we regulate the way that chicken
farms are run
because the regulations meet some
standard of evidence that
if we don't regulate the waste from
large chicken farms it's going to
pollute Downstream
um
bodies of water and so we start with
some scientific evidence we make sure
the regulation fits the harm that is
could potentially be done by by badly
built chicken farms and you know the
result is a moderate moderate moderately
regulated industry
and we try to address those from time to
time no regulations perfect
um I think building codes are a good
example of a
a good but imperfect body of Regulation
um people who are deep in the Weeds on
building codes will say oh no they're
terrible there's all these little things
which is ultimately like you look at it
you say okay there's a technocratic body
that updates building codes the building
codes are the same for everyone
more or less Nationwide with with small
exceptions or difference in it in which
edition of the building code they use
but if you're a builder you basically
know the rules
um and you can work anywhere
and this the
process for updating those rules is
based on evidence right so it's
um civil engineers and physicists are
doing experiments and figuring out what
stress loads different materials can
take and
um uh policymakers are setting some kind
of
um
tolerance for error right so we say like
okay if an earthquake fits three
standard deviations bigger than the norm
happens like we don't have to be
prepared for that and those are those
are policy calls and how much risk
you're willing to abide by for what cost
and so it's not perfect and there's ways
that building codes can and do and
should change
but that's what Mo that's what
regulation that is respecting property
rights looks like
um the second the second for State
preemption is fairness
so if local governments are tilting the
playing field systematically against
some New Hampshire citizens right people
who the state government
takes into account as its constituents
but a particular local government
doesn't because they don't live there
the state can counterbalance that right
so if if you've got
I don't know say if the beach Town said
the beaches are only for you know
residents of the beach towns and nobody
else can can go to the beach anymore
um the state could step in and say no
that's you know this is a state resource
and although it's located in your town
you're not allowed to pass regulations
that that completely prohibit public
access to the beach you can pass some
reasonable regulation that balances the
costs of traffic and pollution it makes
the visitors pay for cleanup Etc
um we do this I think all the time with
with industry
um
Commerce for taking into account
The Wider interests of the entire
Commonwealth the entire state
and saying
um we're going to make sure that local
laws don't go beyond what's fair to
everyone
fairness there's arguments about it it's
not it's not like a you know slam dunk
you say fairness and you get whatever
lie you want but there's an argument to
be made there
and then finally the the third argument
for State preemption is to solve
Statewide problems and in this case the
burden of proof is flipped so here I
would say the state has to meet a burden
of proof before preempting that with the
first two I said the localities need to
meet a burden of proof especially that
person localities to to limit someone's
property right they need a burden to
prove it we need to do this to solve
some kind of local problem
flipping this around
if the state wants to solve a Statewide
problem like say the Statewide problem
is uh unemployment's too high so we'd
like to have more jobs okay that's a
Statewide problem that's a reasonable
problem to solve
but to somehow preempt the towns maybe
to take away some property taxes so they
can even give a tax break to businesses
or something
you need to meet a burden of proof as a
state legislator that this is really
the best way to and the lowest cost way
for us to do this
um and again it's not you know it's not
like you just say this and you get to
make the law of it if you can make the
argument that there's Statewide problems
of housing on affordability of
um inability for workers to live near
their jobs
um inability for employers to find
people to hire
right so if you can make that case and
say there are Statewide problems here
um or you know environmental problems
Etc and then we're going to
take a targeted approach that that is
focused on
addressing this problem and it does
involve preempting the towns but here's
why that's logical so I think you can
make the case there but that's a much
harder case to make than simply saying
hey you shouldn't restrict people's
property rights to run a home daycare
so then ultimately the issue for you you
as you consider bills that would preempt
local Authority is whether the local
Regulators can make a compelling case
that a specific regulatory Authority not
zoning is not just like one thing that
is a big package deal with all sorts of
limits on what they can zone for so a
specific type of zoning regulation
is that sufficiently important
to meeting the local needs
to Merit restricting right of citizens
to use and enjoy their private property
and whether that case is then outweighed
on the state interest side
by other citizens outside the towns
they're interested in housing
availability
or Statewide concerns such as
Environmental Protection housing
affordability and economic growth
all right so
that's my argument for whether to
preempt it so how to think about
preemption and I wrote that in testimony
as well so you might have seen it before
um
now how you know even if you've decided
yes it's absolutely worth it we should
do some preamp the towns somehow that
doesn't tell you what you should do and
it doesn't tell you whether specific
actions will have useful consequences
as we categorize State actions into five
buckets
um and this is in the don't go all
reading this because it's long but the
menu of options is organized this way
so the first of those five buckets is
what I just called direct limits on
local regulation so an example of that
would be capping or eliminating parking
requirements so uh state of Connecticut
right said for apartments you can't
require
um more than one parking space for a
one-bedroom apartment and
maybe two two for a three bedroom
Statewide
and so that's just a direct limit uh it
doesn't require any executing Authority
it's just immediately you write it and
it is done and that the towns have to
abide by it
um and that's that's appealing because
it's simple
um
I think the limits on that are that
you've got it has to be very broadly
applicable right so you can say a
parking requirement cap applies
everywhere and we don't have to know
that much about your local contacts to
know that someone living alone only
needs one car
um
what gets harder is if you want to say
hey we want to treat Town centers
differently than rural areas and you
know
it's not impossible but the lawmaking
gets trickier there as you want to start
taking into account
textual factors
the second bucket would be streamlining
procedures I think New Hampshire's
housing appeals board is an excellent
example of this that we we've taken
promote sometimes in other states
and you know specifically for New
England states made up of small towns
with limited staff
uh anything that streamlines procedures
has to really involve technical
assistance
um and even in even in California where
they've done a lot of procedural changes
they've found that the biggest cities
are sort of capable of doing these
themselves and even mid-sized California
cities of you know as big as the larger
New Hampshire towns need State technical
assistance
um to rejigger some of these procedural
things so I think there's actually
streamlining is a really rich vein of
potential State action
we don't have a lot in the menu of
options about that because it's so State
specific every state uh has its own sort
of version of a Kafka novel of how you
get or fail to get housing permitted
and so examples of that I think some of
the most fruitful and simple examples of
that can involve
um
moving types of decisions to simpler
bodies
um so I
this might be in Arizona this year one
of the bills that's under consideration
um don't call it might not be Arizona
don't quote me on that
um there's a certain type of of
land use permission that currently by
State Statute has to be granted by
the city council level body and it would
allow them allow cities to move that
down to ministerial staff approval staff
approval is the easiest level of
approval it doesn't involve politics so
you know when staff says okay the zoning
code says you know you can if you meet
these conditions you can get a
conditional use permit to put a store
here and the fact that the neighbors are
unhappy about it doesn't really matter
because you've met the conditions
the elected officials
they look at the same law and they're
like ah it looks like you meet the
conditions but my voters are really
unhappy about this and I'm getting a lot
of angry letters so I'm going to find
that you don't actually get the kids
um it also just is harder as a
scheduling basis to find time on a city
council schedule to approve every little
thing so the more things you can move
down to the staff level
um the quicker and simpler those become
again in really small towns
um
there things might be really different
because you might not have a full-time
staff member
so you have to think about your specific
circumstances and how to do that
streamlining so I think that some of the
folks that you're you're bringing in uh
who have that granular level experience
in in individual towns individual
Builders they'll be able to inform that
so I encourage you to do that but I
don't have a lot of specifics for you on
how to do streamlining
uh fiscal policy is a third area
um aside from Simply subsidizing demand
there's a lot you can do to get
incentives right
the places in the U.S that have the
biggest housing crises uh uh California
and Massachusetts
have some of the worst fiscal incentives
for housing production
right so a huge difference between
California and Texas on building housing
aside from all the political differences
that you would immediately think of is
tax law Texas has really high property
taxes and low income taxes so when
somebody builds improves property in
Texas the local government is thrilled
because they get to tax it
in California
the property taxes are capped at a
really low rate and they're distributed
according to a bizarre formula that
gives a difference every different city
a different share of their capped
property tax
and so for California cities every new
property is a fiscal burden and they
have to kind of go back to the state and
beg for more money for everything that
they do
um and so when you get so these perverse
incentives where development doesn't pay
for itself
then the entire city apparatus becomes a
an anti-development force of its own
because then the whole budget process
has become becomes more difficult when
you get growth
so whatever you do fiscally you want to
make sure that those incentives for
everyone involved
make sense you don't want to say
you know free affordable housing
buildings of all tax liabilities forever
and that have the cities go the towns go
oh my gosh I don't want to I don't want
to have affordable housing here it'll
never pay its way
right so you want to make sure that
most things most of the time are paying
their Freight that there isn't a huge
bias
um towards one type of land use over
another so states that have a local
sales tax end up over Zoning for
commercial they're all trying to get the
Walmart because boy if you're the time
that gets the Walmart then you're set
for life with your sales taxes and if
you miss out on the Walmart you're
constantly like skimping and scraping
around the edge
um the fourth category that we've got is
narrowing the scope of zoning Authority
it's a little bit different than the
direct preemption and
you know this this really thinks about
not specific types of zoning but but
ways that zoning is done maybe an
example here is better than better than
how I can talk about it
um it's one of the things that we have
in the menu of options that I think
would be very relevant in New Hampshire
is to
by Statute block zoning that makes
existing conditions illegal this isn't
something that happens a lot in small
old towns which New Hampshire has many
many of where the the zoning code that
gets adopted is written by some
consultant
and basically copied and pasted for
every talent that they do business with
with very minor changes
and they aren't coming out and using
tape measures and figuring out what
setbacks actually are in you know the
historic Center of
Concord or a Durham and so they might
have setbacks from the roads like the
how far the house has to be from the
road that's appropriate to the first
town that they wrote this model code for
but has no relevance in your town but if
you want the cheap consultant they're
not going to spend a lot of time coming
out with tape measures to your town
they're just going to copy and paste and
say like what five changes do you want
um
and I think what makes so many old New
England towns so great is this old
pre-zoning character these places were
built before before modern zoning uh
long before
and modern zoning just was not designed
for them and you could you can come back
you can get a more expensive like
form-based code consultant to come and
fix all this but again if you're a small
town that's hard
and the simple thing here for the state
to do is to say
the localities shouldn't be illegalizing
what already exists
um and I made a positive argument for
like hey what already exists is usually
great we love it there's also a negative
argument like maybe the town doesn't
like what already exists and says like
ah we'd love to get rid of all this
um and make our town something that it
isn't but they probably shouldn't right
that's probably not the appropriate role
for government like I don't know we stop
for gas in Salem on the way up and like
everyone in Salem's really ugly no
offense anybody from Salem here but it's
not great I can imagine a zoning code
you know zoning administer coming in and
saying like hey we'd really like to
change this and make it much nicer so
we're just gonna like ban what's already
here and anybody who builds anything on
this strip now has to build it according
to a completely different standard
now there's room for public improvements
like if the if they want to tax those
people and then spend money to put in
like a nice Boulevard and trees okay
that's that's a role for government and
they should debate that put that in
their budget
but regulatorily Banning everything
that's there and saying like we'd like
to be a nicer town than we really are
that puts this burden on property owners
of every time I want to like add an
addition or do a major renovation
I've got to get a variance to stick with
my existing non-conforming land use
um a lot of New England is
non-conforming so Somerville Mass is
most famous for this there they do this
at the city level
um they went through and analyzed their
whole city and found that in the city of
Somerville
population like 90 000 or so they found
27 buildings which might comply with
design code
um and they weren't even sure about
those because they didn't analyze
parking if they departing into account
those 27 probably also wouldn't have
complied their whole city was illegal
according to their zoning code and so
they threw it out and they started over
and said like okay let's do something
totally different but that's a big
expense of operation by a substantial uh
relatively affluent suburb and um
you know I think for for a state one of
the ways that you can address this is to
say like you you know the zoning the
zoning shouldn't be doing the job of of
making everything illegal and trying to
regulatorily create revolutionary change
um
please I've been talking foreign
just said um I don't think I mentioned
the introduction but I'm the the
legislative Council for the town of
Newtown in Connecticut which was
originally settled about 1705
um
there's a historic Main Street there in
historic district that obviously the
town is very proud of
that was developed over many centuries
you know there's some houses there that
date Back to Before the Revolutionary
War on house lots of all different sizes
some on very large Lots some on very
small Lots although the zoning that is
currently there which dates back to the
1930s requires one acre perhaps
but if you actually look at the historic
Zone up between 70 and 80 percent of the
houses are non-conforming with that so
the zoning that is in place
is in conflict with the historic
character that's trying to prevent the
house for example one of the old houses
were to burn down you couldn't rebuild
it on the same lot without a variance so
something like that I think becomes yes
it's a matter of fairness and
consistency but simply as a matter of
sort of regulatory purpose and benefit
how do you really justify that that sort
of zoning which is in conflict with its
own context
um in terms of a public health or safety
concern like what is what is the purpose
of that zoning whose interest is it
protecting uh what is it doing and
that's something you'll see actually in
a lot of New England towns um I think
there's been some appreciation for that
some attempt to perform that I saw that
um concord's proposed new zoning code is
introducing a 2500 square foot lot size
minimum for some of the neighborhoods
around downtown which is comparable to
the patterns of development you'd see
back 200 years ago
so I think there's there's a growing
appreciation for that but I think in
some of these cases where there's this
egregious non-conformity with existing
conditions you have to wonder what what
exactly what purpose is serving if not
an exclusionary purpose or simply a way
of
having the town oversee in detail every
single change it's made through an
extensive variance process or special
permit process just to make simple
changes to a house like rebuilding a
house that's burnt down so just another
another data point to consider
thank you that's great yeah it reminds
me we worked with the city of Auburn
Maine
um on a really extensive rezoning that
they did and one of the outcomes that
they that no we didn't expect they
didn't expect but was really nice was
that once they
um kind of pull stripped back a lot of
regulations they had this flood of
um renovation permits pulled so people
who probably would have been approved
via variance or special permit to add a
deck or you know re-roof an old garage
or something like that but they had to
go through that hassle of getting
permission from the city even it's a
pretty minor hassle in a place like
Auburn
um even that was enough to dissuade them
and so they had this sort of sudden
surge about 75 million I think in
um renovation permits maybe I'm making
that number up
um that seems big for Robert anyway uh
it was big for Auburn whatever the
number was it was big for Auburn and the
number of Renovations they got and I
think that's just a great example like
people would like to reinvest in their
property
and even even a small permitting barrier
or uncertainty about whether they should
kind of go get plans written up for 500
bucks or something is enough to dissuade
them
um the last of my five areas of um
potential State preemption is on
construction standards and again this
can be very mild this can be merely
giving cities and towns permission to
adopt
um something that's more permissive so
the the area that's getting a lot of
attention right now is single staircase
buildings Washington State and Virginia
sort of and um I think one or two other
states are considering uh adding I think
California considering allowing single
stair buildings with higher fire safety
standards
um
which allows the building of uh
multi-family on on narrow Old Town Lots
so it's again fairly useful in an older
older development pattern places where
you'd like to sort of you know have that
kind of
um
tall skinny apartment building instead
of the big wide parking platform or
parking donut type that makes sense in
on a you know 10 Acre Site you're like
okay we've got a quarter acre in a city
what can we put here
um so that's that's useful you know I
don't think that's a huge application to
New Hampshire there but potentially in
Manchester and
a few other Town centers
all right so then to talk about other
cities so this is where I'll actually
say do look at this the front of this uh
we'll hand out
I just picked uh six states to highlight
um
these are reasonably comparable I'd say
these are some of the busiest states in
the country right now every state that's
in session is looking at housing reforms
Republican Democrat
across the board everybody's at least
arguing about it and some are going to
be making pretty sweeping strides in
this case uh this is a little bit out of
date as of like yesterday you can add
three more check marks in Arizona's
column
um three more a couple more bills came
out of committee there so these are
almost all represent bills that are
either out of committee or that the the
majority party leadership is behind so
they are not baked in but they have a
reasonable chance of passing in
Washington and Colorado you've got
uh oh and Montana you've got Governors
to Democrats and a republican in those
cases who are the principal champions of
zoning reform in their states
in Arizona it's coming from
uh legislators likewise in Massachusetts
and
um and I think I actually don't know
much about the Vermont case so that's
the the closest to home here
um
but as you see there's just a huge
amount of potential reform we would not
have been able to make anything like
this a year ago
um there would have been a much sparser
table uh everybody's looking at
accessory dwelling unit
um legalization I think that's the most
obvious of the cases where
there just is not a good regulatory case
to say that you know you can have
someone living in your house but you
can't let them have their own bathroom
or door or kitchen
um a lot of places are looking at
allowing duplexes and fourplexes on most
Lots that's obviously been introduced
here in I think hb44
um different states are looking at
streamlining permitting processes like I
said those are different across all the
states parking minimums
um the one that that's closest to my
heart now all six states are looking at
some relief from lot size minimums
that's something that was not on the
agenda we've done a lot of research on
um Charlie was one of the first people
writing about that five or ten years ago
and and Mercedes done a lot of research
on on lot size minimums and I think
especially for enabling lower cost home
ownership as opposed to multi-family
buildings both of which are important
but if you want to get that
homeownership piece you need smaller
Lots because you just can't make the
land cheaper without letting people buy
smaller pieces of it so we're really
encouraged at the
you know amount of
um you know State consideration none of
these have been signed into law yet
um so we'll see what happens but we're
excited about that
um
and
then there's some systems in States and
they're not on here
California has the longest standing one
Massachusetts
uh has a pretty long-standing version of
this and now New York's Governor is
trying to put in place what I'd call
sort of like a Rube Goldberg
approach where you've got like a bunch
of different like
classes of towns and ways of evaluating
like are you or are you not building
enough housing
um and I can see the appeal to it where
you've got you say like hey the towns
get to
you know choose their own adventure as
long as the results are good and the
states will vary the state will verify
that the results are good and if they're
not then there's some Builders Remedy or
some some preemption that kicks in if
the results are bad
and in theory I think this is really
nice in practice it ends up being very
complex
and
um kind of conflict generative like
there's always an arguments between the
states and the cities and lawsuits um or
between the cities and the builders in
Massachusetts they go back and forth
over over 40b
so
I don't want to say don't do it or don't
consider it but I would definitely worry
about that in a state made up of small
towns that
you'd end up kind of demanding a lot of
in terms of reporting requirements and
some of the towns are small enough that
just like if you happen to go through a
three-year spell where no developer
brings a permit your zoning might be
perfectly fine but you're not going to
show the growth just because you're a
small area and the arrival of permit
applications is kind of random
um so I don't think that's the best
system but I but I kind of respect
the the political science behind it and
trying to say like we really do want to
let the localities Govern but they need
to show us that the outcomes are good
um and so that's that's kind of a whole
other approach so we didn't want to take
up you know 90 minutes with talking
um Charlie if you've got anything else
to say jump in here but I'd love to take
questions and just make this a an open
dialogue
representative Gibbs
thank you Mr chairman
um
first of all thank you for an excellent
presentation
um and I'm going to have to of course
read through all of this uh looks very
interesting
um I have two points slash questions one
very minor
um the other not so minor the first is
about the word Township
um
are you aware that there are
municipalities in other states
specifically in New Jersey
um uh where uh okay I had no idea that
the word Township came from De
tocqueville I've only read bits and
pieces of detox building translation
um uh but there are municipalities in
New Jersey that are officially townships
uh that's their name I grew up in one
yes yes um and they have Township
government
Etc uh so just wanted to make sure that
the word Township is not actually a joke
no no it's but
a division so the entire Northwest
Ordinance region which is the state's
um you know from Ohio to Minnesota they
have these Square counties and each
county is divided into four townships
New Jersey and Pennsylvania have
slightly different townships uh yes we
have townships that are essentially
towns but they're mostly large rural
districts that are now partly Suburban
um so yes okay uh the other thing uh
which is is more substantive
um and before I I
ask this question I'll mention the fact
that I grew up on a farm with a father
who was extremely sensitive about people
interfering with his use of his own land
um however
um uh
have you considered the balance between
um the need for more housing and
specifically people's need not to be
homeless the balance between that and
the need of property owners to be able
to do what they choose with their own
property
um and that perhaps the need not to be
homeless
should be a little higher in the balance
weight than the needs of property owners
to do as they choose with their property
um you know just a
I get some response to
um that sort of concern I I think those
I think those issues are in some way uh
complementary
because when we're talking about
uh in general what we're talking about
here in terms of State preemption or
state regulation would be
limiting the scope of the town's
interference with individual property
rights
so I I think the ability of a property
owner to do what he or she wants with
their own property
and the about the the ability
to develop additional housing
opportunities within a town
a really come down to the same basic
some underlying principle but being free
to do what you want with your own
property that would include say if you
wanted to you know run a run a farm on
your own property rather than
subdividing it for housing being able to
to do that and to undertake whatever
uh you know activities are customarily
associated with it whether a lot of
raising livestock planting crops
um anything like that but on the other
hand it also gives property owners the
ability to build more densely than they
might otherwise be able to which will
will not
directly pertaining to the issue of
homelessness and policy interventions
from homelessness
I I think in general it's acknowledged
an increasing housing Supply
meeting the demand that's there
moderates increases in rents and ends up
benefiting people of all incomes so um
I I don't at least from my perspective I
don't see a conflict between those
allowing people to do what they want
with their own homes and their own
properties can can benefit both those
instances
thank you uh further yes comment
um yes I wasn't suggesting that that
there is a con which really identifies
that you know even though most people
who
end up homeless
um couldn't afford to rent like their
own one bedroom apartment even in a
cheap City
cheap cities have far fewer homeless
people and so there's some mix of
you know how how easy is it for you as
somebody who's you know completely out
of work you have no income you don't
have a Housing Voucher what are you
going to do you're probably not going
and signing a lease you're probably
staying with a friend or an aunt who's
got an extra bedroom
and that having some margins around the
edges of a housing market where people
have a little bit of extra space
um ends up allowing people sort of
through relationships or you know local
non-profits to solve those problems it
also makes the state's funding go a lot
further right so if you're a state and
saying like Okay
let's let's you know be serious to
address our uh homelessness problem with
either assisted
let's say you know Supportive Housing or
vouchers
um the housing and land costs sort of
determine how much budget how much you
can do with it with a budget pot so like
La is trying to build its way out of you
know a hundred thousand two hundred
thousand homeless people but it cost
them six or seven hundred thousand
dollars a pop to build
essentially studio apartments
um so they just back themselves into
this corner and you know there's the the
market kind of helps you on both sides
on the sort of the the most
um
the richest homeless people the homeless
people who have some income right if you
build more housing the price is going to
lower and some of them will be able to
house themselves
um or pay a little bit of rent to family
and friends and then the people who
really aren't going to be able to house
themselves without helping the state
will state be able to help more more of
them as the cost curves gets pushed down
for
state-sponsored vouchers or you know
that's
um so yeah I we agree there's no
conflict we certainly could make this
presentation with a little more emphasis
there and you know maybe if I had
another another cup of coffee or one
fewer that's where it would have ended
up
thank you thank you um representative
thank you kind of building on the last
question
um
do you have any information about the
government
um in New Hampshire
incentivizing non-development
um and
how much impact that has has had
specifically current use
um and how other states might be
incentivizing
um kind of like
like tax breaks for farmland and and
just non-developed land in general
sure I've certainly been
bought a golf course to prevent it from
becoming a subdivision and it's just
sitting there
um Peabody Mass was just in the news for
buying up a piece of land that they
didn't want develop into housing so it's
certainly done I I don't know New
Hampshire's laws be happy to learn
just at least from my own experience I
know Connecticut towns have the
authority to offer certain tax
reductions or abatements for
um
use of property for farming purposes
which I think is fairly common to the
extent to which it's actually promoted
agricultural uses I don't I don't know
it's it's a sort of uh a here and there
sort of a patchwork
um but uh I know it's um it's
significant enough abatement that you
know it does seem to
be encouraging some reuse of older
properties for farming purposes
representative McConkey
thank you Mr chairman
um you piqued my interest on several
items that you spoke of
um and I'm wondering if you can provide
further information single stair
limiting parking minimums
um I'm assuming just to be real quick on
it that this single stair are stack
units or is in with each floor have just
one or more than one apartment
so I think you could do it with two
apartments pretty easily um
technically with a single stair you
could you know there's no there's no
physical limit on how many units you
could put but typically
um the value of that comes from
relatively narrow buildings and the
ability to have Windows on
two or three sides of a unit instead of
just windows on one side of it and if I
remember hearing you correctly you
talked about to do that to sweeten the
pot higher fire safety standards or
higher construction standards on those
units yeah right so the you know the
U.S abides by something called the
international building code which is a
bit of a misnomer because it's not used
much internationally
um it's US and Canada basically and
most other developed countries allow
single stair buildings
height
you know one of the reasons for having
two staircases is fire safety but
obviously there's other ways to achieve
fire safety and so like you know the
goal is to achieve a certain level of
safety
um not to achieve safety through one way
over another
so you can you can sort of make these
trade-offs and say okay you have to
achieve the same safety that you choose
staircase building would achieve but if
you do that through a mix of split
sprinklers or heavily rated walls
um or you know type 3 Type 4
construction instead of type one
um then that's great thank you if you
could follow up with some parking
minimum because I I live in rural
and our lots are small and there's been
a lot of strides to make more happen
density but then when it comes down to
parking it's a killer so if you could
follow that along and one that I've
spoken to if I could Mr chairman I
apologize without asking one of the
things I've talked to a lot of our
concert everyone's saying we don't have
enough land to make Workforce housing
affordable housing and several of my
towns are over 50 or 60 percent of their
land mass in conservation easement
and so many of those maybe I'm wrong but
many of those conservation easements
could not open up the process again to
allow 20 or 30 Acres if they could it
would it would make you know
an interesting conversation on one type
of land and how much so I'm wondering if
there have I'm cautioning them on New
easements to make you know some
condition to make that happen are you
aware of of any model conservation
easements that are being worked on that
would be more
promoting of a housing component
so um good group of questions so working
backwards I don't know of anyone who's
done this but what I would suggest for a
new conservation easement is to pair it
with up zonings that sort of offset the
potential loss of developable land
this has been done through again more
Rube Goldberg type systems like in
Montgomery County Maryland has a
successful example of sort of tradable
or if they wanted to preserve their
farmland and they let the farmers sell
their development rights to sort of
urban areas where extra growth would be
welcomed
uh lots and lots of places have imitated
that and they haven't worked so really
Montgomery County and New York City are
the only ones that have worked and
they're very large jurisdictions where
there's lots of buyers and lots of
sellers don't try to make that work in a
New Hampshire
um
but just as a matter of like the town
meeting making this decision saying like
hey if we if we take a conservation
easement on such and such a land
you know this is this could have been
developed as 50 homes let's make sure we
zone for a capacity 50 homes where we do
want them and so there's sort of a
budgeting like a
um a net zero uh change in regulation
and that sort of fits in I think a lot
of people's concepts of like we would
like to encourage growth to be where
Services already are where it's not
changing the the natural environment
much and um
you know I but then the argument comes
you actually have to like find a place
to up Zone and
um
you know the people any any specific
spot people find some excuse not to
upzone it
um on parking minimums
uh lots and lots of cities Nationwide
have gotten rid of parking minimums in
their downtowns or city-wide
um Auburn Maine which we worked with
they got rid of commercial parking
minimums entirely and took residential
down to one per unit and I just think
generally
developers build the parking that they
think they need and
so the big gains from changes in parking
are
where the government just doesn't know
what the business needs so in Auburn as
soon as they change the requirements
they had two interesting proposals so
one was uh and these are not like I mean
your Mercedes these are not walkable
businesses one was um Olive Garden the
other was Target right these are very
much car oriented businesses and
cariented locations
Olive Garden wanted to buy an old
restaurant shell
um that just wasn't quite big enough for
their business model and they wanted to
sort of punch it out and add
five or ten more tables worth of space
um by taking over some of their parking
lot they were able to do that because
the city gave them the flexibility on
the parking minimums and they said we
don't you know we have this many tables
this many parking space we don't need
all the parking spaces we need more
tables
and then Target similarly bought a pad
site that had been I don't know Toys R
Us or something and they wanted to
expand the floor space they didn't need
as much parking so I actually think
commercial is where you can get a lot of
benefit you're not getting housing from
commercial obviously
um
but in terms of efficiently using your
land uh we just you know the these
parking minimums that are written into
code
they're just guesses nobody has any idea
nobody has done a study
um
that has any external validity every
business in every location has a
slightly different need and they're the
ones best positioned to figure that out
so lots of cities have done it they
don't stop building parking but they
build it in different places so like
Buffalo did this Buffalo in Buffalo the
big benefit was it allowed reuse of old
buildings which Buffalo has a lot of
um more easily so they'd had a problem
with these old pre-car era downtown
building said No Parking On Site
they needed variances to get reused and
reactivate it's either sitting vacant
and the city benefited enormously from
just getting rid of the parking minimums
and letting people repurpose uh
buildings without having to worry about
parking and so
your customers are going to have to get
there and if they don't like that's
going to be your problem
um occasionally I'll get local leaders
to say oh we need this because otherwise
people park on the street well park on
the street is a problem address parking
on the street you can do that with
stickers you can do that through no
parking on main roads
um address that like a lot of times
people try to use zoning to address some
backdoor problem and it doesn't often
work like people do large lot zoning to
address
you know storm water concerns but then
people are like putting pesticides on
two acre Lawns and it's like well this
isn't actually solving the problem that
you wished it would solve address the
problem
don't address this other thing that is
tangentially related to it
any other questions
representative Ocala
thank you
um thanks for taking more questions
um
I I like your
um your
thoughts on kind of like making existing
conditions illegal because the home that
I currently live in is illegal
um so
um I I liked also your kind of like
phrasing of kind of maybe the state has
a role in
um instead of this kind of what New
Hampshire has is kind of like oftentimes
rural character is is often used and
maybe we need to change that to
historical character of the community
instead of rural character
um and
um how does
how did you see some of these um like
proposals uh
um kind of like being instantiated or
being proposed because what I'm thinking
about is something like you know
um you know within a certain number of
feet of my house you can have the same
conditions that you know the same
setbacks that my house has what what
were the types of um
um like preserving of the historical
character have you seen
in some local zoning codes I know you do
see some accommodation for uh characters
saying for example a setback can be
determined based upon the average of the
surrounding houses and things like this
that at least attempt
um to acknowledge that there is an
existing historical context and that
requiring somebody to be
building Anew to build something that's
completely different in scale and
setting from the existing homes is not
preserving the historic context uh you
know you see it here and there usually
in response to individual cases where
somebody says this clearly this code is
not a protecting our the historic
character of our town at all
um but I think
um as far as a
state level
perform that number one that's something
that could be reflected in the enabling
statute itself
um Connecticut in 2021 recently
performed made some major changes to its
enabling statute to reflect some of
these additional concerns and actually I
think they took character completely out
as a consideration although another
another way might be to change the type
of character that's being protected
because I I know you typically hear this
um at least this phrase New England the
rural character of the town which is
somewhat of an oxymoron right it's like
the town it's the country it's like what
are we what are we protecting uh and it
becomes a little bit confused as to
what's um you know what the underlying
goal is so I think clarifying some of
those purposes from a Statewide
perspective like what other resources
we're we're trying to protect which is I
think it's already reflected somewhat
which it says you know protecting
Agriculture and Forestry and a balanced
supply of housing you know reinforcing
the the best qualities of the existing
towns while protecting the best
qualities of uh you know farmland and
forests and historic natural resources
and you know strengthening each of those
rather than promoting a
super LeapFrog a pattern of development
which you see now where
um you know developments occur
just here and there according to
happenstance and who acquires a
particular parcel of land so I think
that's one way of doing it also uh yeah
the other approach is is directly
intervening for example
I don't know if this is the current
legislation that's proposed in Vermont
but it was one they had a couple years
ago was simply setting lot sizes in
areas served by city services like areas
where there's a sewer and water and no
concern about
wastewater treatment
or septics or anything like that and
simply setting some bottom line
standards saying in those areas where
there's already existing density we're
going to say you can't set a lot size
minimum more than ten thousand square
feet there's just no justification for
that for requiring things that are
completely out of character with the
existing zone so if we see that all has
no Health Banning farming on their
outskirts
um which of course is what people were
doing there a long time before the
suburb came along and so that the
legislature stepping in to actually
protect the farmers right to continue
farming
um but the way that I would do the sort
of protecting existing conditions it's
easier in a settled area where you've
got the concept of a block
where you can say like if a block has
you know if you know you take like the
the
two-thirds or three quarters percentile
so like you can't you can't uh
and enforce a regulation that would put
a quarter or a third of the houses on
this block or the parcels on this block
and do not conformity
that'd be one way to do it
um
you could do something like a a physical
distance like 200 feet that would be
able to work the benefit of that is it
would work in rural areas as well
um
do you think in rural areas there's more
of a
validity to say
um all right well there's you know
there's a few scattered buildings along
here but this is not settled according
to a certain pattern and so that if it
gets built up We Want to Build It Up
according to this pattern
and there you're
you know a little bit more in keeping
with the idea of what zoning is supposed
to do
um in the in the fully fully built out
area
The Zone it's like sort of that the cow
has left the barn like if you wanted to
develop it under pattern a well pattern
B is already in place and you should
just respect pattern B and it could it
could also go to uses so if you've got
an area where
there's a mix of uses
the town couldn't come along and say
um you know residential is banned here
commercial is banned here if it's mixed
use it gets to stay mixed use and you
can't tell somebody
I can't switch in One Direction the
other if it's already a kind of an
established use in that area but I think
it'd be something to workshop and kind
of sit down with the towns and say like
hey how would this affect you how would
you interpret this how do we think about
rural areas because that's where my
thinking is I think the most unclear
um but I think there's a lot of cases
where towns would say oh yeah we we had
we had no intention of enforcing this
regulation we always give people the
variance when they ask for it and just
saying like hey you know it seems to you
from the town perspective the variance
feels cost less like you just do a
little business and like you get a fee
but from the point of view of the
property owner
the variance is this big uncertainty
they don't want to start the project as
even a tiny bit of uncertainty
um and just removing that uncertainty I
think can really help them
representative Walsh
thank you Mr chair thanks for coming
here's some looks like a lot of helpful
information here on some of the
solutions bear with me for a couple of
minutes I've been taking notes through
your whole testimony I wish we had
stopped a couple times in the middle so
let me try to summarize all these
I guess I'll start with looking at your
introduction overly restrictive local
zoning is the fundamental cause of
America's housing shortage that's your
position you're not the first one to
come here saying that is so
and then you've referred to municipal
government
um as the impediment and that's why the
state should preempt some of these
zoning restrictions
have you done a town by Town study
because I've always been under the
impression that the majority of zoning
varying zoning ordinance are actually
adopted by the citizens of the towns I
believe the cities and some of our sb2
towns it's actually the local governing
body that makes the or has the authority
and I thought the balance overwhelmingly
was actually adopted by the citizens on
either the warrant or town meeting have
you looked into that because if that's
the case I don't necessarily agree that
it's the government that is causing this
it may be the citizens
I mean so we could we can have a debate
about townships and towns and whether
whether the town meeting is the
government
um so I you know
whether I wrote that you can you can
gloss in town meeting for for as the
form of government I think it is a form
of government okay
um if if uh from a legal perspective you
want to draw a distinction there fine I
you're absolutely right you know places
that have a town meeting are adopting
their ordinances correct we just
defended the citizens choice and
Hooksett last week at our delayed
meeting so so I am corrected the
majority of our municipalities it's the
citizens that decide these things we can
you're right debate whether that's
local governing body or not uh but
getting back to that and again just so I
can have some credible
or some credibility when I'm looking
through some of your suggestions again
now we're talking about the government
as the impediment and that's the reason
the state government should preempt
the only thing I heard you mention is
reasons for the pressure on demand is
covid-19 and remote working as the sole
driver from people coming from
Massachusetts you might want to look at
the Millionaire's tax and a bunch of
other things they're doing down there
that are making people come here were
there any other things that you think
are pushing on demand or applying
pressure on the demand side
I mean there's lots of things Nationwide
so this is not a New Hampshire problem
right this is if this is a 50 state
um problem
uh there are more American households
than there were a generation ago we make
more money we demand more living space
the
you know if you look at that graph
of housing prices you'll see it was
steadily Rising through 2019 at the
beginning of 2020 and then summer of
2020 it takes off
it was still Rising before covet 19.
um
um I think covid-19 to work from home
are especially relevant in a place like
New Hampshire that's within range of but
not the you know core of a major
metropolitan area yep so there are there
are absolutely lots of other factors and
then
some of the cyclical stuff is going to
be driven by interest rates
um certainly not denying that those are
going to come and go you know don't make
your long-term laws to try to deal with
what the FED did yesterday but
um yeah we We As Americans we want to
live in bigger and bigger houses we want
more and more space
of course and I agree those are
legitimate reasons for it and again I'm
not trying to I understand this is
information just again trying to get an
understanding of what you put into the
research before I can take the
information out of it and use it
um and we keep talking about government
as in strict of uh zoning is a problem
and that's the reason we need to preempt
but if we're going to talk about the
reasons and and causes by government
because I'm a firm believer you need to
know all the causes before you can come
to Solutions have you looked at illegal
immigration I know it seems like uh the
elephant in the corner nobody wants to
talk about but when we know we have
millions and millions of people coming
across the border in the last few years
they're going everywhere have you
studied how that is affecting
the supply side of housing in all our
states I mean so the funny thing like an
honest answer here I'm not trying to
troll you
um
a a significant issue in the 2010s boom
was that there weren't the kind of cheap
uh workers you could pick up at Home
Depot
um to do timber Framing and drywalling
that there were in the 2005-2007 housing
boom it's one of the reasons that even
though Prices rose just as much in like
the 2014 to 19 time frame we didn't
build nearly as much housing
um but you know we've done Texas is
probably the state where we've done the
most work this year they they certainly
um know about illegal immigration they
have a lot of people uh who both legally
and illegally have migrated to Texas
they managed to House people who don't
have a lot of money
um they managed to put home ownership in
reach of
um working Texans by building a lot of
house so you know wherever the demand
comes from illegal immigrants don't
demand much housing because they don't
have much money like ultimately demand
is a function of like how much you can
pay
um when I look at it as units
sure but you know it don't like
if you look at number of people who
occupy a housing unit right so
um the uh the affluent person who's able
to say like I want a home office every
one of my kids gets their own bedroom
like they're using up a lot more of uh
the square footage
in a city than the family that's living
12 to a room doesn't mean the two
absolute room is not there not denying
that they're absolutely a source of
source of demand
um but I I
don't see any correlation across the U.S
that makes me think that that's a
significant or a major driver of what's
happening now it's certainly less of a
driver than it was 15 or 20 years ago
when there were a lot more illegal
immigrants in the country
if I can thank you sir have you uh cost
wise on the uh
inflated rents and record home prices
um what if you refresh my memory what
were your major reasons for the spike in
price short of the government caused
inflation again these are all policies
that are out of our hands we're looking
for Solutions here but a lot of the
problems I see are are problems that
were developed by our federal government
not so much US inflation was not caused
by the state of New Hampshire and you
know and our energy policy was not
adopted by the state of New Hampshire
but yet both of those things play a
major role in the cost of development
and rental prices because most of your
rentals actually have heat and hot water
included so I just again I'm just
reiterating how much of this stuff
you've actually looked at to come up
with your summaries
yeah no those are those are absolutely
real factors um I think it's really
important to look beyond the current
moment um just as you you know you
pointed out like does covid-19 stuff
that's maybe temporary and we shouldn't
base all of our conclusions on that I
simply rape is also you know we were
doing this work before you know the
inflation of the of 2021 2022
um and we saw basically the same problem
right you know so inflation
shuffles the deck slightly differently
but fundamentally you've got a nation of
the growing population and growing
wealth that has stopped building uh
housing at the rate that it used if you
look at how many housing units per
thousand Americans we built in 1950 or
1960 or 1970 or 1980 or 1990 or 2000 or
right up to 2008 it's higher than today
we are building housing at the peak of
our economic expansion when we were a
booming country with very low
unemployment we were building less
housing per person than we were in
recessions in the 20th century we're
below recessionary levels from when our
parents were trying to buy their first
homes so I
it's obviously a complex problem housing
touches everything and everything
touches housing so there's nothing you
can bring up that'll say oh no no that's
totally unrelated house everything's
related
but you can't tell me look at the data
and tell me oh we've got enough housing
it's just these other things it's these
guys in Washington like sure they affect
it
but there's no musical chairs by which
you can take a growing population and
say oh we're going to stop building
enough housing for them and then have to
be enough housing like there's just no
like there's nowhere to put all those
heads in beds
um at the the rate that they're
demanding
of course
um I agree with you in entirety in terms
of looking at construction standards and
building codes uh as a as a problem and
just I'll agree I'm a carpenter and the
developer as well so I know all about
them they're ridiculous
have you looked
um because I'm hearing this from other
avenues too have you looked at this or
maybe are you going to look at it it's
not just building codes um
overburdensome and over regulated fire
codes I'm starting to see those I'm
hearing from developers that those are
probably worse than the building codes
to begin with have you looked at that
angle because they're hugely expensive
for some of these regulations
so usually when I I'm not building
firecracker usually when I've seen them
there together what's what's the
difference if you're looking at them
together that's fine thank you thank you
and and
um representative we had somebody from
the New Hampshire building code
officials Association was supposed to be
here today not feeling well so we'll
have them at the next meeting you'll be
able to ask about that as well thank you
um representative Gibbs thank you Mr
chairman
um just following up on the previous
question
um am I correct in my understanding that
new immigrants and particularly illegal
immigrants often live several households
per unit
well we Define a household by people who
live in a unit together so it's kind of
it's a tautology well perhaps several
families per unit certainly certainly at
higher occupancy level than
it thank you
anything else okay I'm gonna ask a
couple but please okay so
um can you explain
um
I know when we last met we talked about
protest petitions can you talk about
that a little bit
um because going on the local level
about how citizens control zoning
ordinances I'd love to know a little bit
about how we can reform protest
petitions to affect you know maybe make
it a little bit more difficult or a
higher standard to right stop
development yeah great question
um
so 20 states in the U.S have protest
petition laws uh to have a weird
referendum thing and the other 28 don't
have any such law so this is not
Universal
um in states with a protest petition law
if someone if the town wants to rezone
whether through their own initiative or
um
because a citizen asked you know would
you please ReSound my property so I can
do such and such
if neighbors within a certain radius I
don't have the New Hampshire set you in
front of me at the moment but if
neighbors in a certain radius
um sign a petition
uh against the rezoning then it kicks up
the
uh required majority at city council or
town meeting
to a super majority
and makes it much much harder I think
especially in a town meeting context
to pass a resume
um and there's a bunch of reasons that
this is not great law so one is that it
only enfranchises property owners and
not renters
um so uh a case that I I wrote obviously
in Texas uh It was a commercial District
so all the all the property owners are
commercial property owners somebody
wants to build an assisted living
facility and the owner of vacant land
next to them protests and gets the thing
killed because
maybe they thought that they you know
whatever they were planning to do with
their land someday didn't mesh well with
Assisted Living they'd like something
next to them that is drawing customers
to the area to patronize their business
whatever they end up building right it's
like that's not an appropriate use of
the zoning power to let one commercial
landowner
you know shaft and other commercial
um because they'd like to make more
money right like that's not what we make
something for
um
the other the other feature of that case
that that highlights a failure of the
participation law is that it's minority
rule so in Most states I'd have to again
look up for New Hampshire Most states if
20 owners of 20 of the surrounding land
protests that triggers the makes the
participation valid and triggers the
super majority requirement
so in this case one one neighbor
protested but four neighbors wrote in
support and said great you know please
please approve this rezoning we're happy
to have the assisted living facility
next to us and there's no there's no
offsetting it's not like if you get 80
in favor of 20 opposed it's still as if
the neighborhood opposes it
um so there's a bill in Texas that would
kick that up to 50 so it would leave the
law in place it's a big deal in Texas
but it would at least make it you have
to actually get a majority of the
neighboring landowners a minority can't
trigger the petition
um
and Massachusetts did reforms last year
two years ago
that allowed up zonings for more housing
to be essentially exempt
um from they have so Massachusetts had
the most restrictive rezoning law in the
country so it required a super majority
of city council or town meeting for any
rezoning whatsoever we had to get
two-thirds voted and so Governor Baker's
reforms
pushed that down to a 50 level four
reforms that would allow more housing so
that sort of tilts the playing field a
little bit in favor of Housing and I as
a as a uh person who likes the idea that
government should meet a higher bar for
regulation
um I like the idea of 50 to to lift
regulations 66 to impose regulations
Massachusetts is not perfect it doesn't
help commercial rezonings at all
it only affects certain kinds of
pro-housing rezonings
um but I I see what they're doing there
and I I like that concept can you give I
I know you gave a commercial example
could you give a residential example of
how
first of all what our laws look like
here and then give maybe a residential
example of how you know if we do lower
the state lower the bar how that would
affect the outcome of that of that
example so I don't have a New Hampshire
examples off the top of my head
um one that I know of in Oklahoma again
far away
um
a
defunct Hotel wanted to so somebody
somebody wanted to buy off defunct Hotel
turn half of it into a veterans homeless
housing and half of it into a hotel
um and obviously like
the hotel part's not going to work if
there's you know nuisances coming from
the the homeless veterans right like
they thought they could make this work
and make money on their hotel part while
also providing housing to homeless vets
this is great this is what we want right
people solving you know stepping up to
solve homelessness on their own
The Neighbors which included uh
uh Christian University and a Walmart
signed a protest petition and Oklahoma
probably has the already like the
countries of the 20 states that have
these laws probably the best model
um it's still cleared their 50 threshold
and
um killed or at least delayed that I I
don't know what's the come of that case
that was a couple years ago I was
probably just dead at this point
um
but again that's a case where
somebody was going to try to provide
housing to a particularly needy
population
um and even with that higher threshold
it's not a great example because it
doesn't tell you like oh if you just
made this little change you would fix
everything
um but you can kind of make these
marginal changes you can push the
boundaries out so that the buffer is
bigger and means that it is less likely
to just be one or two uh grumpy
neighbors to kill a project you actually
have to get serious neighborhood
opposition
you can certainly kick it up to 50 You
Can Count renters or all registered
voters in the in the buffer
um so that people who are prospective
renters are like oh I would like it if
there was nice new rentals in my
neighborhood
um as opposed to I just don't want
anything to change I got mine and my
property values Rising every year
um I think all of those things would
help at the margin
ultimately like two states just got rid
of the law entirely North Carolina and
Wisconsin repealed it in
North Carolina there was like one study
and two or three little paper articles
in a local paper Wisconsin you can't
even find a mention of it in the news it
was so trivial so unused
um they were able to get rid of it I
don't know if it's widely used in New
Hampshire
um or if it's kind of used so often
people don't even know that the water is
wet so I think both of those I've seen
states where both of those are the case
and so I'd have to do a little bit more
New Hampshire specific research maybe
maybe I did before we talked last time
and I knew what I was talking about I
haven't looked at it
um in the last few weeks well and and
that would be helpful to inform the
committee maybe if you could look into
that and provide us feedback on that
because I'm looking specifically at how
those protest petitions uh restrict um
specifically adus and other units that
are being built on existing property I
think it's something we'd like to look
at thank you absolutely
um yeah we have we're rolling over a
little bit but does anybody else have
any questions represent broody
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you very
much for coming and speaking to us this
morning
um I know you gave a lot of examples
about a lot of things
all around the country however we're in
New Hampshire uh I think we're very
unique in New Hampshire we're a small
state and we see an enormous influx of
people from New York Connecticut and
especially Massachusetts
selling their High products price
property there coming up here and
outbidding everybody all these local
people these kids who were born and
raised here trying to buy their first
home they're out of the market and
that's that's what I'm really concerned
about they have no shot at all
um the only thing I think and I know
what I don't know what we can do on a
state level as far as relieving packing
I think is a big thing I'm a
Massachusetts broker as well and I've
sold property in in Cambridge and
Somerville uh four or five family units
with zero packing they find a way to you
know live there so I think parking if we
could light lighten up on a parking for
one thing especially in the cities but
these small towns who are
really controlling their own you know
towns that they want your town to stay
the way it is and there's not much that
we can force them to do but um just keep
up the Integrity of the State of New
Hampshire but it is a unique problem
that New Hampshire has
a small state of surrounded by people
that want to come in so and thank you
for coming again thank you I think
Montana is actually a really
um good peer to look at is very
different physical environment but the
economic environment is very similar
where it's Californians in their case
and it's further away but the it's a
very small number of Californians to
make a lot of montanans
they've seen prices just absolutely
Skyrocket
um and I I really applaud governor
gianforte and our we have a good friend
there who runs the think tank Kendall
cotton at the frontier Institute they've
just taken the lead and said like We
Can't Stop The Californians there's no
legal way under the U.S Constitution to
say that California can't move here and
bring the 1.2 million dollars of home
equity that they have and outbid the
montanans and we have to build enough
housing for everyone
um and so they've taken a very strong
like we're gonna build our way out of
this
um because there's no you know the U.S
Constitution you can't stop people from
coming in
um but I I would absolutely take a look
at them and and kind of the the common
problem that they're dealing with
and there's people that come in with
much much more money than what our
people have yeah because you get to cash
out in the big city yeah absolutely
yeah I just add to that I guess that's
that's also an issue with um some of the
air the the states surrounding New York
um Connecticut as well where there's
been a huge run-up and
property prices over the last couple
years so you've seen a lot of people
during the pandemic moving out of New
York coming up looking for uh maybe
they're working remotely now
so they're looking for an opportunity to
live a couple hours out from the city
they only have to go in one or two days
a week so suddenly you have a complete
reconfiguration of the the job market
and these exorbent towns which weren't
as desirable certainly are
um but just like uh Saleem said you see
that um people coming in with the the
money to buy for example just uh buy a
house in cash or uh whatever it is I
mean there's not even any chance to
um to get into a bidding process much
less with somebody who grew up in the
town let's say who's working
um you know just started working as a
teacher at one of the elementary schools
and is looking to find a place they have
absolutely no chance to compete with
somebody like that and I mean I've seen
that happen in my own town people have
had to move out because their landlord
was selling because the the prices were
going up and um
they essentially they lost their rental
and had to move out someplace else so
that the need is as acute and it's
immediate and it's right you can't
um you can't throw up any roadblocks to
keep people from coming out but you can
create new housing opportunities
and hopefully those can be done in a way
that benefit
the locals as well people who would like
to stay in the town create ways
find ways to create that housing housing
options that are appealing and
affordable
to you know uh to locals people from the
area rather than only creating the you
know at the very highest end and that's
something that regulations can affect
um you know knocking down some of these
obstacles to creating a new housing
that's you know not um
you know it's substandard but obviously
affordable attainable to young people
and young families
thank you um have you seen anything
um
uh with uh kind of like off-site
building and 3D building
um
um projects if if states are proposing
um kind of uh
unilateral approval or a Statewide
approval process of a specific design
that can be like replicated throughout
the state and therefore can avoid some
of the you know regulatory costs of
approving each individual design and and
say okay this design has been approved
at the state level as long as it's built
you know with this design then you're
good to go
so that's
a stand away that HUD code manufactured
homes work it's Federal not State
um
I don't know of any states that have
done
um Factory site approvals of other forms
of manufactured housing so usually
this is it's a very it's a very messy
area of of law because you
the physical product and the inspection
process are not necessarily linked so a
manuf a home that is manufactured can be
a HUD code manufactured home where the
HUD inspector comes to the factory puts
a seal on it and then it has approval
for anywhere in the U.S but when you
install that home in a New Hampshire
town there's a good chance that it's the
local building inspector still gets to
come out
and inspect and you know approve or
reject it
um
or if you have a factory that's building
you know modular or manufacturing homes
that aren't HUD code those definitely
then have to be inspected by the local
building crew uh local local building
inspector
so there's a few states that have
required uh that
HUD code manufactured homes be allowed
everywhere where a single family home is
left I think that's a good policy
there's been a a
a major campaign in the 60s and 70s that
sort of the results which persist this
day of attaching stigma to Manufactured
Homes uh that they they don't deserve
it's not the jodes anymore
and
so allowing them everywhere is good but
the a big part of the benefit of them so
part of the benefit is that they're
built indoors so you don't have to deal
with weather delays and so it's a little
bit cheaper
um part of the benefit is that the
inspection happens all at once and you
don't have to have the local building
inspector and
um that also kind of kind of remove like
his
localities can sort of Shadow ban them
like officially the state says you have
to allow all HUD code homes like sure we
allow all head code homes but also we
require that roof pitch B acts in our
town and by the way HUD requires a roof
picture of why and so like never the
twain she'll meet no hudco home is ever
going to meet this roof pitch and that
roof pitch
and so you need a sort of substantial
statute to say you have to allow these
and you really have to allow them and
they're not subject to local building
codes the other reason that we don't
like manufactured homes typically is
that a lot not the majority anymore but
a lot of them are placed in manufactured
home parks which are
like factories for legal problems
because you've got the land owned by the
park owner and the structure owned by
the resident and so you're constantly
getting conflicts and you've got this
captured asset problem where it's like
10 or 15 000 to move the so-called
mobile home it's not actually mobile
um
and
so the the park owner kind of has
captured the resident and can change the
rent and they are much less mobile than
a regular renter who only has to move
the sofa
um and then if the person leaves and
abandons the property well the property
doesn't belong to the park owners they
can't just re-rent it to somebody else
like if you you know if you have a
regular multi-family tenant they walk
away you say okay well we're gonna throw
out their belongings or into somebody
else who knows what happened to Joe
um and then
so you end up with units that sit vacant
until they're like ready to be
demolished so there's all sorts of
problems that arise with mobile home
parks I don't love those
I understand why they exist but but they
they create legal problems the houses
themselves are fine and if you allow
people to fee simple install a house
without a local building inspector that
is the primary source of low-cost
housing in most of Rural America
um and that's how I would say most of
the country rarely works is that people
put these houses on no local building
inspector shows up
for fifty to a hundred thousand dollars
you've got a perfectly serviceable small
single family house
representative Gibbs
thank you Mr chairman
um
in reference to
um mobile home parks manufactured
housing
um uh certainly we have had some legal
problems around here in reference to
uh Park's owned by Park owners and units
owned by unit owners and it's become
quite complex occasionally
um but uh I'm here I'll just give you
one sentence background uh I live in a
condo townhouse uh where the land and
the outdoor the outer part is owned by
the condo association and the indoors is
owned by me
um so how is that different from the
mobile home park situation that you've
just described
so there's no the condo association is
is owned by all the condo owners so you
have no incentive to jack up your own
condo fees imagine if instead of the
condo association it was you know some
right Berkshire Hathaway or some random
dude before Town's over who realized
that he could jack up the condo fees and
pocket the money so I think that's the
difference
well and I think what we're
well we're talking about you know the
unit owners could come together and
create an association or Co-op or
something of that sort there's a great
one great example in Goffstown of how
the property was sold and then the
residents purchased the property and
created it to their own that has
happened locally a couple of times as
well yeah
I think allowing allowing also
subdivision into little tiny Lots
um and you know fee simple ownership is
the most advantaged form condos have had
a kind of bad 20 years in the US for a
number of reasons and
we have a lot of
financial and legal infrastructure
to make fee simple homes work really
well for a lot of people and so
subdividing so if you've got a mobile
home park you're like ah we really like
to preserve this as a as a neighborhood
um
just breaking it up into Lots which is
not normally allowed because the minimum
loss sizes are too small but we've
physically got the same build pattern
it's only to everyone's advantage to
turn these into small Lots let people
own their land and their unit and then
they get access to all of the mortgage
infrastructure all of the legal
infrastructure that protects your house
um and then also the city then has you
know the authority if someone's a
nuisance they can take action if
someone's behind on their taxes
they're sort of all the normal recourse
that we have towards a unified single
piece of property it gets a lot simpler
and I think it benefits residents more
and allows them to then appreciate
invest Etc
um I think condo kind of forms of
ownership are
meet certain needs
um but they haven't they have not
performed very well in the last past
quarter Century I'm not 100 sure why
okay we're gonna wrap up
all right thank you very much that's
been very helpful
um if you could follow up with us
specifically about the things that we've
talked about that would be awesome we're
looking at things regarding adus and
other stuff so I appreciate you coming
by and traveling all to New Hampshire so
thank you very much we appreciate
shopliving New Hampshire
all right we uh we had a uh somebody
cancel from the 11 30 or
10 30 to 11 15 so we're gonna try to
start the next presentation a little
early but let's take a 10 minute break
and
we'll come back come back at um
10 55.
okay Welcome Back special committee on
housing so our next presentation is
going to be from Christopher Parker from
the city of Dover Christopher is the
Deputy city manager and director of
strategic strategic initiatives thank
you for coming
good morning just mind hitting your mic
for us people viewing from home
no it's got to be the red
there you go
technology
again my name is Christopher Parker I'm
the deputy city manager with city of
Dover for way of background I've been
with the city since 1997 including over
20 years with the Department of planning
and Community Development of which I was
the director for I believe 15 and a half
years so I have definitely witnessed
housing changes in the cities
particularly having grown up there and
so I'm happy to discuss our philosophy
discuss the the zoning that we've
enacted in other land use changes and
then take questions if that works for
the commission
so our philosophy is our philosophy is
rooted in a couple different areas the
first is that we want to encourage
private rights private property rights
including development rights and and
protect those development rights whether
they belong to the community whether
they belong to the property owner or the
butter we recognize that all three
groups have vested interest in Land
Development in the community
in the face of housing we have decided
as a community that it is better to be
welcoming and open and encourage density
and development encouraging more people
to participate in our community and be
engaged in our community than to do the
alternative in that regards as we've
studied housing and the variables that
affect housing over the past 10 to 20
years we've recognized a few things
the most important one I think is
recognizing the variables that go into
the cost of housing I'm going to run
through those
they're a bit alliterative and in their
design that way but they're I think they
the terms cover more of a broad area so
the first is land
the cost of land has to play into it
land particularly in a community that's
celebrating its 400th anniversary this
year is a little bit tight and we have
developed continually over the past 400
years particularly over the past 20
years I believe in the
2010 and 2020 census we were among the
fastest growing communities in the state
so land costs have continued to rise and
if you pay attention to the market and
you pay attention to Market forces
you'll recognize that even in recessions
land might stabilize but it typically
does not actually go down it's kind of
like taxes things stabilize but they
don't necessarily go down
the second L that I would refer to is
Lumber and this could be any material
required to build houses I just like the
L of lumber so it can be the nails it
can be the drywall it can be the roofing
it can be certainly the timber required
those costs have considered continue to
go up as well
the third L would be labor
we do not do well as a state Community
or Society of encouraging people to go
into the labor force from a Hands-On
standpoint the average age of a
electrician in this state is 55 years
old
the average age of a carpenter is older
and if you think about what is needed to
build houses it is labor and lumber
you can have all the land you want if
you don't have people that actually can
build the house or if any of you like me
have tried to do remodeling of our own
house or fix something
you'll find that that labor pool has
continued to dwindle and it continued to
go much more costly
take a break for a second on that and go
through some of the cost element that
those three areas bring up
if you think about the cost of a house
and let's use a 1600 square foot house
which I will admit is bigger than my
house but is typically considered a a
middle range house today the cost of
that house would be about 205 dollars a
square foot
on a good day
so that 1600 square foot house is over
three hundred thousand dollars almost
350 000 just to build
let's not add the land in let's not add
the fact that the the Builder isn't
doing it to be altruistic and wants to
profit they are in the business of of
that
so there's a reason why we see continued
escalation in affordability just from a
market standpoint
back to the L's of which there are five
the fourth L is Lending
for a number of years The Lending aspect
was good
if you look back up until really the
past year year and a half
mortgage rates interest rates were very
favorable
and that it was spurring development and
what I would hear often from developers
was the cost of money is so cheap I can
absorb the cost of land Lumber and labor
to make it ameliorate out I can deal
with that what I'm hearing now is
we built houses when interest rates were
in the the mid teens in the early 80s we
built houses in the 90s when the
interest rates were in the high single
digits
we can build houses now at the six
the big thing we're finding with with
um
interest rate Rising is it someone like
me
who has a 2.3 interest rate
is not going to sell their house
and so existing home sales have
flatlined or coming on the market supply
is flatlined or stabilized at or excuse
me receded and that is what's driving
costs relative to that is that the
supply is going down because new houses
are still being built and new house
financing has different mechanisms in
place different programs than existing
home typically a new home they can buy
down points they can reduce that
interest rate assist a buyer an existing
home seller is not going to have that
same opportunity to do so or may not
take advantage of the same opportunity
through their buying power so they're
going to face that and again if you have
a low interest rate
you have to make the decision do I want
to take on a new interest rate and is
the property I'm going to buy that much
better than what I have now
and so we're seeing a very uh dramatic
change than what we saw a few years ago
on
uh existing homes coming on the market
so the fifth L is legislative
and we recognize in Dover that we could
as a community
buy land and sell it dirt cheap we
certainly could try to buy materials or
provide labor but the reality is none of
those things are going to happen
so you come down to financing The
Lending l or legislative and for the
community the most cost effective
measure we determined was the
legislative
so starting in 2010 we started making
legislative changes regarding housing
housing affordability and Housing
Opportunity
one of the first was prior to the state
adopting accessory dwelling unit
regulations the city of Dover put
accessory dwelling unit regulations in
place in fact we worked with a variety
of stakeholders in 2010 and 11 when the
state was developing its regulations and
a lot of them are modeled off of what we
had already looked at in Dover at the
time
we recognized at the time it was both an
opportunity to get new homeowners or
people that wanted to move towards home
ownership a unit it was also a way for
people to stay in their homes one of the
things we constantly want to be aware of
is that housing is not just for the
young old or in between it's for all so
we wanted to be able to provide
opportunities for aging and home by
allowing people that maybe would have
been empty nesters would have sold and
tried to find a place to stay in the
community to stay in their existing home
rent a space to help recoup some income
to bring in income so that was one of
the reasons why we we did the accessory
dwelling unit ordinance
13 years ago
in addition to that we started looking
at our density and and we made a
conscious decision as a community that
we wanted to start building Community
particularly walkable communities and
increasing our density and recognizing
that density was not bad it really came
down to an idea that still resonates I
think and I'll use myself as an example
again I have a 24 year old
I would really like him to not live in
my basement
at the same time I don't necessarily
want him living in California because
that's where he can afford to live
probably a bad example
I would like him to be able to live in
Dover just as I moved out of my parents
basement and moved into an apartment in
the community and and then bought a home
in the community and raised my family
there I want the same for him so we try
to personalize it and look at it not as
a
a how do we encourage Outsiders to come
but we recognize that we want to help
provide an a way for our own Community
to grow and stay in the community
whether they are empty nesters or
starting out in the world
so we recognize that density is a way to
do that so we created about that same
time a transfer of development rights
ordinance and the transfer development
rights ordinance idea is
you want to preserve and protect open
space
and at the same time you don't want that
property in order to lose their
development rights so they can then
transfer them somewhere else so we
identified at the time a mechanism and
it was based upon the Spalding Turnpike
which effectively bisects the community
if if my hand is over right down the
middle is the Smalling Turnpike and so
the ordinance at the time said
if you own land to the west of the
Spalding that tended to be our more
rurally designated zoning and land uses
if you own land there and choose to you
can provide the density to someone on
the east side of the Spalding
so there was typical underlying zoning
density allowed Etc and you were able to
take that and there was a formula that
was created
I like to say that I'm not an engineer
because I don't do math I'm an architect
for the same reason so the math on this
was really bad
but the formula allows you to go from A
to B
and that existed
unutilized for eight years
2018 we said okay we need to figure out
a way to make this utilized and so we
re-looked at it from the standpoint of
land banking and we calculated the
amount of money the city through its
conservation efforts in in other ways
had put
land into conservation and protected it
we calculated the value of that we
calculated the cost per acre and we said
you can reimburse the city and buy the
development rights that the community
has bought again our mindset is that the
property owner has has development
rights the city has development rights
and the butters have development right
so this was a way to take into account
those two
so at the time
again this is 2018 we calculated that
the city had spent thirteen thousand
four hundred and two dollars per acre
on land preservation so we said you can
buy density from the city
and place it anywhere in their criteria
it's not as blanket as
we're going to go here it is a
articulated zoning ordinance
and we said we're going to allow this to
occur
and then the design the design of
affordability came up
and so what we said was we want to
encourage affordability in our master
plan specifically said
set at the time and still says even
though it's a newer chapter that smaller
units are more desirable that we were
hearing from Millennials we were hearing
from Baby Boomers we were hearing from
people that like myself and my wife that
want to downsize
that they want essentially the same
thing they want places to hang their hat
and to have experiences out of they they
are less inclined both of those age
groups to want to
paint the house every couple years fix
the boiler worry about the the roof
caving in
mowing lawns they have other things they
want to be doing with their time they
want smaller unit
thousand square foot was the the unit
size that we had heard a lot of so we
came back and we said okay
13402 is the the general price however
if you're willing to create a 1400
square foot unit
we will allow you to pay two-thirds that
cost nine thousand dollars
if you are willing to do a thousand
square foot unit you can pay six
thousand per
the trade-off is those thousand and
fourteen hundred square foot units are
deed restricted for no expansion
no additional space
and the idea was when we looked at the
market at the time there was a very
different cost
per square foot for homes that were a
thousand or 1400 square feet they
typically were
um closer to the two and a quarter to
three and a quarter price point
then larger units the 2200 square foot
2500 square foot much closer to the five
550 entry point versus this desirable
smaller
square footage
so this seemed like a good idea and we
were getting a lot of interest in the
first year I think we raised over a
million dollars for the conservation
fund through
the selling of the density and locking
in
the problem we found is the market
and the market is a very good thing but
it also likes to do what it wants to do
so
what happened was I would buy
a development right and I would say I'm
going to limit this to a thousand square
feet or 1400 square feet
and then I would start building my house
and I would put it on the market and the
market was so strong that someone would
come along and offer to buy it and then
they would say you know what
I don't want Builder grade I want Cherry
cabinets I don't want laminate floor I
want X floor I don't want formica I want
Granite quartz name your countertop I
don't want the 8 by 10 deck I want a 22
by
18 deck and all of a sudden those 1400
square foot units which were listed on
the market for three and a quarter we're
selling for a 450 to 500 000.
so we thought well
on the one hand it the ordinance did
exactly what we wanted to do it spurred
increased growth it spurred smaller
units but it was not getting the
affordable aspect
so we we met with Builders because one
of the things that we have done in the
community
since about when I started with the
community is we have said look unless I
win Powerball I'm not going to be a
developer
so that means that whether it's myself
the planning board the the zoning board
or the the city council we can make
regulations all we want but if we can't
find people that want to use them why
did we create these ordinances if
they're not usable by the public by the
landowner it's then their useless
ordinances
so we we continually meet with
development professionals whether they
are developers attorneys
Financial or surveyor Engineers we meet
with them and say
how would these actually get effectuated
and through that we kept hearing time
and time again there were two major
things that drove the price of
development from their standpoint one
was time and one was money
the longer the process the more they
have to send an attorney to a meeting
the longer that that occurs or the more
costs they incur the more they pass that
on to the end user the second was the
the cost so we looked at our fee
structures and we said short of giving
density and saying we don't there is no
value to density which is a bad thing
what can we do
so we came up with a change in 2020
that says
those three layers still exist
the unrestricted the 14 in the thousand
but we added a new layer which was HUD
fair market restricted
and we said if you are willing to build
a unit
and restrict the value to the HUD fair
market value as published by New
Hampshire Housing Finance in April of
every year
then there is no cost for that unit
the difference the the distinction is
similar to how the other units are deed
restricted so they can't be below above
14 or a thousand square feet in this
case the unit is is forever deeded as
uh meeting needing to meet those targets
and
unlike the other programs where we say
whatever your your base density could
have been let's say that this table is
my lot and by the base zoning I could
get eight units on it and I use the
transfer development rights program to
buy an additional three those three are
the ones that would be restricted at the
Thousand or the 1400 but the original
what what my rights to to start with
would be unrestricted and would have no
impacts
in this case we said
we're going to make that change
different
those eight units you could have gotten
by right those also have to be
deed restricted so the whole thing has
to be restricted
we've had one I think fairly public
success with that uh on Back River Road
in Dover we have a project called The
Cottages the base density on the seven
acre lot was nine units they're building
44 units
they are 400 square foot units
they're one bedroom they are designed so
that you have indoor and outdoor space
they have Farmers porches they have an
area where you will be able to have a
fire pit and outdoor enjoyment they're
based on a design around a common area
so each one looks at the old style New
England common
they have parking that's set aside there
are walking trails there's a community
building so that when you have a party
where you need to fit more than four
people in your your unit you can rent
that similar to a club room that you
might find in a a apartment or
condominium building
there is uh
laundry facility there there no there's
laundry facilities in each unit there's
a gym I believe in that club room
so the idea they had was we need to
to embrace this and that's their their
program
since that project we have approved I
believe five more projects with that
same basic philosophy of developers
property owners have said
if I can lower my barrier to entry
if I can reduce my upfront costs
I'm more than willing to make these
commitments because The Upfront costs
are what they're struggling to overcome
to get shovels on the ground they're
comfortable that the strength of the
market they will be able to rent the
units they will be able to commit to the
unit occupation
and get the the derivatives they need
later on to
carry the cost
it's just that upfront cost that is is
much more of a struggle particularly as
interest rates have gone up and as the
labor and lumber costs have gone up
so I would say that we have had success
in this sort of changing the philosophy
to say we're going to incentivize
density that is the the Avenue we took
of we don't think it's fair to bang
people over the head and say you have to
do this but if we give people an option
we give people an option that appeals to
them and says we want you to be whole
too
there are the reason that that the home
builder is the reason that that the
development Community builds is because
that's their business
and so they need to be respected for
that and they need to be made hold at
the same time
we recognize that unfettered market is
creating a scenario where affordability
is a struggle and so to that regard we
have found this this path to be working
for our community
well thank you very much if you're going
to lost a lot to think about
um I have one question before I take
them
um how is the increased density affected
the stress on the community water sewer
can you talk a little bit about that and
if you've maybe put aside some extra
funding to reinforce
um the extra use that it's getting
that's a great question and I will say
when I've gone to other communities and
talked about this process the first
thing I say is if you don't have water
and sewer infrastructure density is the
biggest
concern you're going to have because
lack of water and sewer infrastructure
is what holds back most communities from
a density we are 80 of our community has
water and sewer infrastructure we
while we have agreed that the cost to
buy the units is something we are
willing to bring down we have not
reduced our water sewer investment fees
and we have not removed our impact fees
so we have impact fees for school
police fire and Recreation and so a
single-family home in Dover it it is
approximately fourteen thousand dollars
of investment or impact fees per unit
to come in the The Cottage units I
mentioned are a little bit less because
they they are one bedroom they're
typically not going to generate
school-aged children in the school
portion of our impact fees is the
highest but the water sewer investment
is specifically to address capacity
issues and to allow us as a community to
continue to invest in our infrastructure
needs and make sure that the water and
sewer infrastructure are in place and
have you seen a
obviously increase stress but have have
those fees been able to
uh balance with the The increased stress
on the yes the the
impacts have not been necessarily
stressful they've been we've been aware
of them but the fees are put in place
and our Capital Improvements program is
designed to anticipate that growth
at the same time
we do not take on off-site impacts or
take that off the table for you so if
you're a property owner that that 44
unit uh
project that I mentioned they had to
make water and sewer upgrades to the
lines in their area to make sure they
could accommodate
that we could accommodate the the needs
it was a it's a back and forth
conversation but through the Capital
Improvements program we are trying to
anticipate continued growth and
direction
great thank you representative Rudy
thank you Mr chairman I think you stole
my question however uh my question was
to include uh your permitting your
permitting fees your building permits
and all that your fire
school fire of course the water and
sewer that's all in it you mentioned
fourteen thousand for a single family
what about the 40 unit building and
excuse me and let's include the actual
cost of the permits that does not
include any building permit or
entitlement fees so if you think about
it the average cost for that project the
44 unit project
um
they probably our site our site plan
review fees are capped at 10 000 per
project
so they they paid a uh the site plan
review fees to go through the
entitlement process and then they paid
any inspection fees those fees the
entitlement review fees as well as the
inspection fees whether they be site
inspections in the engineering office or
the fire Life Safety or building
inspection fees those are all going into
the operating fund to help maintain the
costs associated with the service it's a
fee for service model
so we do not
remove those fees or ameliorate those
fees those fees are the fees they are
what we do is when you come in the
initial conversation with us we give you
an estimate of what we think those fees
are going to be so you can build those
into your proforma because we do not
want you to get down the road and then
say wait a second I didn't realize I was
going to have to pay this
so we have gotten very Adept over the
past 10 years that I don't want to waste
my time so I don't want to have
conversations that sound great and then
have someone come along and say oh I
can't afford this
so we make sure it's upfront what those
costs are and and again we are at a um
we have an application fee a 200
application fee and then it is footage
for multi-family or by unit for single
family the the entitlement review costs
and then the building permit review
costs are based on a couple locations
where your town spoke on this project
so the initial density for that unit for
the Cottages would have allowed I think
you said nine units so did they buy the
development rights that got about three
questions did they buy the development
rights to gain the extra 36 units by
agreeing to do the HUD rental rate
they effectively bought it but there was
no charge for them okay
talked about follow-up capping the size
of buildings so
are you also capping the size of those
Cottages so that they can't come back
later in one ad for an addition off the
side or so forth
they are capped at 600 square feet so in
this case they are building 400 they're
capped at six the layout for those
specific ones are such that they will
probably not meet the building code if
they do any enlargement we did have them
build in some storage space off the rear
from an aesthetic standpoint we
recognize that people have things and we
wanted to be able to like bikes and
things like that so we wanted to
encourage them and I should
should clarify in case it's not clear
the 600 the thousand and the 1400 is
conditioned space
so the spaces might be larger
because if it's unconditioned
us
um
basement crawl space an attic
ventilation those sort of things those
do not count it is conditioned usable
space that is the cap and finally one
more
so as I read about those Lofts and
the the cottages and it talks about I'm
assuming there's a bedroom a grade
but there's also a loft upstairs
so you told me that you know this is
primarily you know a couple or a person
but then the worrisome item for
Town fathers is that they will grow the
family and you'll have the second
bedroom upstairs is that Captain anyway
it's not and when those when that was
going through the entitlement project
the state had not
um adopted schedule Q of the building
code which is specifically targeted
towards
what the market likes to call tiny homes
and so it in our mind
those
Loft areas were unconditioned space they
were being provided as additional
storage space and the way that they are
laid out
it's not full Headroom
so we our agreement with them is that
these are one bedroom units so we
through a development agreement process
locked that in because we wanted to make
sure that there was no bait and switch
conversation we have our end up hold the
developer has their end to uphold
if I could just ask and what is the what
is the HUD rate for that rental unit
when they were approved it was I believe
990 dollars
a month and it is now closer to twelve
hundred dollars a month with utilities
uh the utility I believe the electric is
included but water sewer is not included
thank you very much thank you for the
courtesy
of course representative Gibbs thank you
um uh I have two questions
um uh first
um am I correct in assuming that in
addition to the fees that you've
described
um is the city also receiving uh
substantially higher property taxes uh
for the developed properties then you're
receiving before
certainly when land is developed the tax
evaluation does change and so that is
something we're aware of but we do not
calculate it as part of the process
understand that
um but does that assist in
in
um addressing any for instance Water and
Sewer issues so the water and sewer uh
our Enterprise fund so they are again
user fees so if there is water sewer
usage that is accounted for from an
operating budget standpoint yes we do
anticipate that increased valuation will
help cover the general Municipal cost
police response fire response Etc that
may be generated one thing that is of
note
and and I'm I'm using the the cottage
project but it would apply to any
similar in that case one of the things
we negotiated with the the property
owner was through the development
process was that it would remain as a
single
entity uh governing we didn't want to
have 44 new water and sewer users we
wanted to have one entity that was going
to be making sure the payments were made
at the same time from a life safety
standpoint we wanted to make sure there
was one entity that was plowing and
making sure that there were no
obstructions for response as opposed to
having to deal with 44 individuals thank
you
um and my second question is I hope
simpler
um uh I found
um uh your development incentive really
very interesting
um and I would like to
um be able to read a copy of your
current transfer development rights
ordinance would it be possible for you
to send that ordinance or link to that
ordinance to the committee members by
email absolutely we have uh I have it in
two forms and I'll send both I guess to
representative Alexander did you have a
special email
to you it's House special Committee of
housing great I I can certainly send
that out this afternoon
um it'll be twofold one the a link to
the PDF of the the ordinance itself and
then we have an information sheet that
we developed hopefully putting some of
it in layman's terms uh to help explain
the processes and the opportunities
thank you that would be very helpful
great representative Walsh
yep thank you Mr chair thanks for coming
it is an interesting sounding ordinance
uh aside front she asked the two things
I wanted to as far as more information
on top of the PDF and the Layman's
version any images or anything else you
can provide just to give people a sense
of it sure I can provide the
what we call the yield plan which is the
here's what you could have done plan and
then the here's what they did do plan
we've got a couple different projects
that we could probably look at getting
you
we also have this was one of those we
average in Dover
planning board
review takes one meeting
so we work the staff Works behind the
scenes with the applicant
maybe two months but then it is a one
meeting presentation of the planning
board this was actually a two meeting
and I was glad it was a two because it
was a good opportunity for the developer
and the staff to to walk the public
through not just the board members
through but the public through this
opportunity that was before us
the partners the the developers they
produced I think some great examples of
renderings
of balloon test examples of things
because people heard high density and
they assumed it was much different than
than what it is so I'll provide those as
well because I think that was really
helpful for people to think it's not
people like to use the term tiny house
and the reason I use Cottages is because
we all see the HGTV idea of a tiny house
and that's not what these are
in some ways it's getting back to a more
basic
um living space that that really meets
your needs as opposed to your wants
because folks that are needing to afford
this that is what they're trying to
achieve is their basic needs
representative
thank you thank you for taking questions
[Music]
um
my concern as I'm I was hearing the uh
what was going on in in
your situation was kind of like we
agreed or we negotiated or
um we came to an agreement about
X like the you know it was going to be
all owned by one person or whatever and
that
brings the question of how reproducible
is this
um situation is this kind of a one-off
if you have to make certain agreements
for it or how much was
um just following what was in this
um ordinance that you gave me or that
you're going to provide for to the
committee
that's just like you know boilerplate
anyone could have done this exact same
thing and
um you know can you kind of talk about
like is there was there variances was
there you know
um hurdles that you still saw that would
make it hard to reproduce the same type
of thing elsewhere thank you
so
I am a big purveyor of the idea that
rules are meant to be Rewritten
and that something that was written in
1948 which is when Dover adopted zoning
it very rarely should it be the same in
2023 I have a copy of the 1948 zoning
ordinance and there are things that are
still in there
but the idea was we want to learn from
the the current trends we want to learn
from the past and we want to learn from
what our stakeholders are telling us
to that extent it's been written
so that it can be transferable because
we want to be sharing with with other
community members uh the the planning
director uh Donna Benton who
unfortunately could not be here today
she is the president of the New
Hampshire planners Association and she
thinks of things from the standpoint of
we need to be sharing
so the ordinance itself I think is
highly transferable
it is a search and replace Dover for x
the other portions
I think are
shouldn't be transferable in the sense
that your community and its reaction to
a site plan or a subdivision plan needs
to be calibrated to your community as
opposed to what dover's was I mentioned
the the
um
maintenance and the snow plowing and
things like that the fire chief was the
one that said
at one point the layout they were going
to have to lose 10 units because they
couldn't meet the fire code of distance
between where the the access way is to
the front door of the unit
the fire chief came in and said I
understand how important this is
let's think creatively
and we looked at it and he said if you
did this and this and we did this and
this
you can get those 10 units
but in order for us to feel comfortable
with that we need you to say we're not
going to leave it up to the individual
tenants to shovel their walkway in the
winter
we want a
a agreement that you are going to as the
management company do this the company
said we take pride in ownership and we
don't want
to see dishevelment either so it works
for us
those sorts of things are in a
development agreement which is easily
templatable and and we've shared both
the ordinance the development agreement
as well as other aspects of the lease
the lease agreement that that is part of
the approval which says number one an
improvement on the site to provide
visitor parking and the leases say if
you have a visitor this is the visitor
parking space not over here
the this was one I I felt unfortunate
about
the initial plan had a community garden
that was going to go in the front of the
property along the main road the
neighbor said that they did not want
that that they were against that because
they assumed that it would be positive
in the beginning and then people would
lose interest and it would look
overgrown and weedy the developer said
that they would not include that
component the developer originally
talked about doing solar panels
and to help offset
electric cost the neighbors said they
don't want to see solar panels solar
panels are
ugly just like Community Gardens are and
so they reworked the layout to address
that
the biggest butter that that uh came out
was ironically the person that sold the
property to
the property or the developer who
did not think that the the density was
going to be as high as it was and they
came out and they said we want more
money which the planning board
thankfully said that is not our purview
and
he wanted he wanted a different curb cut
for his own house because his house was
next door and they were able to to work
that in and work a couple things in what
I'm getting at is in every case there
was going to be a butter mitigation
the the density conversation comes into
play because one of our criteria is it
has to be the density has to be
in keeping with the density and
intensity of the neighboring lot so the
in order to get the ordinance the
property owner has to show that these
are not going to stand out like a sore
thumb in the example we typically use is
if you have a single family neighborhood
and someone came in and they said we're
going to put in a a 10 10 unit single
building
that would not be keeping with the
spirit and intent of the neighborhood in
this case there were singles duplex and
triplexes all within
uh the I believe it's 250 foot in either
direction
um review area that we have including a
10 unit right across the street
so there was it was a much less of a
concern in that regard further up the
road we had a different project that
they came in they said they wanted 80
units where they could have gotten 40.
uh the I believe at the end of the day
the planning board agreed to
um about half of that
and when the planning board agrees to
give you the additional unit count
it says this is the most you can do you
now go through the site plan process and
if you can't fit it because the
engineering and the site work doesn't
work
don't come back to us and say
figure out a way it's up to you so in
that case
that project got approved for somewhere
closer to 60 and they ended up doing
closer to 50 because the storm water
management all of the other aspects of
the site planning came into play the
ledge Wetlands Etc and that's that's
another thing I should put out there is
the planning board has been very clear
that it is not interested in
um
as a point uh
point-blank conversation it's not
interested in saying Wetlands Wetlands
buffers steep slopes
uh stream beds
you will give you uh conditional use
permits to get around those for density
it says you have to make the case you
still have to apply for that relief you
still have to justify under the local
and state code why we should we should
Grant this environmental relief and show
us that there was no other way to do it
because density is good and we want to
promote it but the other hand there's a
balance and we want to make sure we
maintain that balance okay so it seems
to me that you're saying the butters had
an issue whether it was going to be 9
units or 44 and you did your best to
alleviate those concerns but at the end
of the day the planning board out had to
make a great call okay correct
all right representative Walsh just a
quick question
um just to give my until I see the
information just a general sense
how big was the lot you were looking at
if it's 12 homes I must say I'm assuming
at least 12 acres and what was the
zoning in the area at the time
would you believe it's seven acres
so the zoning is 12 000 square foot
minimum lot size
so it's uh well that's actually our
Suburban density
um our our largest zone is acre
um and it's we Dover uses contiguous
Upland not square footage so it's 12 000
contiguous Upland
uh our
our more urban is down to four thousand
square foot Lots so in this case the the
Seven Acres was going to yield nine Lots
because they're steep slopes there's
Wetlands there's Wetland buffers there's
a stream the Bellamy river is in the
back side so there was a Shoreland
overlay District
things of that nature so
they got the developer has said they got
44 units on three acres because that's
when you when you look at the specific
build a build area I say it's on the
Seven Acres because the storm water
management and the the trails that they
provided and the things of that nature
take up the full seven acres
are there any other questions
perfect well thank you very much for
coming and we look forward to you
sending us an email regarding uh the
site plan and everything so we can look
at that you're very welcome thank you
for having me and I am always available
and happy to chat as is Miss Benton who
could not be here perfect thank you
so with that we're gonna break for lunch
so let's uh we have a presentation on
the zoning Atlas at one o'clock so we'll
see you back at one
uh we are going to hear from our last
presenter today I want to welcome
um the saint ansem College Center for
ethics and Society to come up and
present some new research on the New
Hampshire zoning Atlas came out I think
this week right so I want to invite up
um an old college professor of not of
mine but at St ansem College
um that I knew while I was at College
Max Latona and then I'd also like to
invite up Ben Frost from New Hampshire
Housing and uh Jason sorens from
I forget
the American Institute for economic
research welcome
okay thank you um representative
Alexander in the committee for inviting
us here today
um you've already been introduced to us
I do want to say that the three of us
um are part of the leadership team for
this project that I'll be describing in
a moment there are a few others who
couldn't make it today and I'll mention
them as well
um uh but we're very happy to be here
today to give you what is actually the
first Glimpse to the new um of the New
Hampshire zoning Atlas a project that
has been under development for well over
a year since December of
2021 actually
and our purposes today is to sort of
give you an overview of the project talk
about the process by which it was
completed
some of the major findings that we've
made as a result of the project some
potential policy implications and to
give you a sort of an advanced
demonstration a little demonstration of
the atlas itself and how it could be
used
um so
without further Ado we'll just uh talk a
little bit about
um some of the basics of the atlas
um
so as I mentioned our leadership team
that developed this uh is really there's
really three organizations that are
um uh Partners in developing the atlas
it's the center for ethics in society at
St Anselm College
um the New Hampshire Housing Finance
Authority and uh the office of Planning
and Development the State Office of
planning and development and
representing the office of planning and
development is Noah hodgets uh the
principal planner he cannot be here
today
due to illness
but in addition we also have a wonderful
GIS specialist a rick leader of Barnes
who did incredible work on this project
he could not be here today as well and
finally Sarah Martian
um some of you may remember her from her
work in Nashua uh as well as with the
Northern New England chapter the
American planners Association she is
currently a chief of staff at our the
Community Loan Fund so uh that is our
leadership team
um and we've been working on this
project now for as I said uh 12 to 13 of
14 to 15 months
so the first thing I'd like to talk
about is a little bit is what is the New
Hampshire zoning Atlas um
and quite simply it's a collaborative
project to research catalog digitize and
graphically display all of New
Hampshire's zoning regulations Community
by Community District by District
um why do we need such a thing well um
as you well know I'm sure zoning is
complicated in New Hampshire it's
decentralized
um you know as as we know there's going
to be there's over 250 jurisdictions in
New Hampshire Each of which has been
granted its own authority to uh to
provide to create its own land use
ordinances
um so it's inconsistent from one
jurisdiction to the next what those
zoning rules or land use ordinances say
and even within a jurisdiction from one
District to the next and I dare say
we've found inconsistencies within
single zoning codes as we went through
the project so lots of inconsistency all
around zoning is is complex as you know
there are layers and layers upon
regulations that can govern housing
production
um includes housing treatments but also
dimensional regulations on additional
things like parking and so on and so
forth full of jargon zoning codes are
difficult for the average person to read
you have words like accessory use and
buffer zones conditional use setbacks
easements Frontage impervious surfaces
and so on so it's difficult to
understand Zoning for the average person
it's also piecemeal just in terms of how
these zoning codes were developed over
time it wasn't systematically done in
most cases but each year some change or
addition is is introduced into the code
and in the end you have basically a very
much piecemeal
set of rules and that are not
systematically streamlined so
given all of those complications our
zoning Atlas is intended to help
communities and policy makers in New
Hampshire simply understand our zoning
understand the zoning within a given
Community but also collectively across
the communities and
to understand how that how those zoning
rules impact housing Supply and
affordability
so what we really hope to do with this
Atlas is to generate a healthy Statewide
discourse about our land use ordinances
and how they impact housing Supply and
affordability and we think understanding
is the best tool to facilitate that kind
of discourse and this is what this Atlas
is intended to help help us understand
our zoning so
so that uh that's uh
simple overview of the project I do want
to acknowledge our partners who made
this possible I've already mentioned the
center for ethics and Society New
Hampshire Housing and the office of
planning and development in business and
economic Affairs but we also have some
funding partners that have been very
important I'd like to thank citizens uh
Charles Koch Foundation the mercatus
center ever North and New Hampshire
Realtors all have been very important
for producing this project I also want
to make a note or nod to our national
Partners as you may know there is a
national zoning Atlas project going on
um led by Sarah brona not of Cornell
University and there are a number of
other states at least 30 or so that are
currently working on atlases so we're
part of a growing I think Consciousness
and awareness Across the Nation about
zoning regulations how they impact
housing production and we're excited to
see um this kind of work happening
across uh
the country
um just quickly our timeline and
Milestones so as I mentioned this idea
was generated in December of 2021 in
January of 2022 we assembled our
leadership team who I've already
introduced to
um and by March we secured funding for
the project
um and in April May we hired our zoning
if you wanted to really dig into these
data you can do so we're going to make
these um publicly available for free
online so that researchers can use them
and really anyone can use them there are
two data sets one is sort of the the raw
data which is a a Google sheet anyone
can get into there and and and look at
that and it's got all the zoning
districts in the state
um base and overlay districts it
includes districts that don't appear on
zoning Maps like a lot of flood plain
Wetland and aquifer protection districts
that are not actually map units are not
allowed so residential districts could
be one of two types it could be
primarily residential which means that
not much commercial or industrial use is
allowed there they could allow some
Agriculture and Forestry use could allow
maybe churches
utilities some some government functions
but if they don't allow some general
category of commercial or industrial use
we code them as primarily residential
mixed with residential means they allow
both residential and some general
category of commercial use
non-residential districts come in three
types
we assessed whether they're primarily a
commercial a General commercial District
primarily an industrial district or
primarily just a conservation or maybe
agriculture District where neither
commercial nor residential uses are
allowed
then we take into account youth zoning
of various types so we we look at
whether single-family homes are allowed
duplexes or two family three family four
family and then five or more family
units are allowed right so that has to
do with a number of units allowed in a
single structure
uh we code features relating to
affordable housing if they're a special
benefits or requirements for dwelling
units that are guaranteed affordable so
there's a legal mandate that they'd be
affordable to people of a certain income
then we have that information in there
accessory dwelling units or accessory
Apartments as they're sometimes called
we have several features of those
available and how manufactured housing
is treated so those are some examples of
the the kind of use categories that we
capture in the zoning Atlas and then in
addition to that we capture a
dimensional and parking regulations so
that includes things like minimum lot
size minimum Frontage minimum front
setback minimum side setback minimum
rear setback maximum lot coverage
maximum height maximum number of
bedrooms
a number of these a number of these
features uh that you can think of we
have in our data set so we are talking
about ultimately about 200 different
variables or fields in this data set
um
you know capturing everything from
minimum parking requirements to
dimensional regulations to use
categories we also capture whether a
district allows dwelling units that are
elderly only for a certain type so maybe
it allows three family structures but
only if they're limited to elderly or
maybe they allow three family structures
but only if they're guaranteed
affordable so we capture
those characteristics as well
um so this is a lot of information so
feel free to ask as we go along I I have
a question how did you account for Flex
Zones commercial industrial or
commercial residential like how do you
is are there data points for those yes
so um so those would be classified as
mixed with residential if they allow uh
mixed use or if they allow both
residential and Commercial structures
um then that's a mix with residential
district
um so we are able to show you although
our focus is on housing we are able to
show you
um what parts of New Hampshire allow at
least one General category of commercial
use
um and and that's fairly interesting we
see that
um I'm just going to kind of make a
generalization here that in in the more
rural parts of the state actually
there's there tends to be more land
available for commercial and Industrial
use and maybe that's part of their
strategy to grow their tax base whereas
in the more kind of suburban
Southeastern part of the state
um you have a lot of districts that
exclude commercial entirely
representative Gibbs thank you
I speak your
secure from experience
um is there such a thing as commercial
agricultural
yes so uh by under state law
agricultural use is allowed throughout
the entire territory unless it's a
conservation only area
um so there's there aren't any
municipalities that actually prohibit
um agricultural uses that wasn't my
question okay
um are there areas where where
agricultural use is allowed
um but there are restrictions on
commercial use yes yes so
um we have as a category of
non-residential District we have a
conservation slash agriculture category
so those would be districts where
residential is not allowed commercials
not allowed Industrials not allowed but
agriculture might be so
commercial use in
exactly for housing use exactly thank
you
um and it's and another good point here
if we really want to get into the weeds
is if it allows commercial uses only
through special exception or something
like that we do code it as commercial
being allowed even though that's a kind
of special permit so long as it doesn't
require an actual variance as we know
the the criteria for a variance can be
quite restrictive and there's no
guarantee of getting one
um so that's that's the approach we took
yes I'm going to go through a few of the
findings and then hand it over to Ben
Frost
so just a a little bit of what you're
going to see once this is
um goes live to the public on May 9th
you'll be able to go through a section
of the zoning Atlas website called a
story map and it has a kind of
analytical description of features of
New Hampshire zoning along with
illustrative Maps
um and then we're also going to have in
there and we're going to talk about it
briefly today a really detailed analysis
of Manchester and the surrounding
communities and how they zone for
housing
there's also going to be an interactive
Atlas and you're going to see a
demonstration of that today uh and I'm
very excited about this this is a
feature that I think is going to get a
lot of attention and use it will allow
you to show
um
what parts of the state are available
for single family two family five plus
family with minimum lot sizes between
various types where elderly only housing
is is allowed where affordable only
housing is allowed
um so that you're going to be able to to
do a lot of things there and you can
click on any uh zoning district and
you're going to get the whole set of
attributes for that zoning District so
again if you really want to to dig into
it you're going to find all those things
I just mentioned that we have in there
are going to be available to you so the
whole thing
the whole thing will be searchable
you'll be able to search for an address
and it'll pull up that zoning District
that address is a part of that's
incredible representative Reed
first of all I just want to apologize
for coming in late uh absolutely no
disrespect meant I'm super excited about
these tools that you're developing this
particular one will the type of housing
allowed in the area be like so where a
mobile home is allowed versus not or
modular is one that I seem to always get
fuzzy on where that's allowed so that
will be yeah so um in the interactive
Atlas I I don't know that we have a
filter set up but maybe this is
something we could set up in the next
month it sure would be pretty easy to
show where Manufacturing Housing is
allowed we do have some static maps that
show how manufactured housing is treated
but to make that part of the interactive
Atlas would be would be a cool idea
representative another one and this
might be slightly off topic but going
off of what representative Gibbs had
brought up in you speaking on
agriculture so there's nowhere in the
state on the state level the state you
said the state guarantees that
agriculture is allowed everywhere
so is does that mean that towns don't
have ordinances that prohibit certain
agricultural activity there are certain
types of Agriculture that they can but I
believe it's and Ben you may know that
the law on this I think is tilling of
the ground or something like that is the
phrase in state law
crops
everywhere so you can you can keep your
garden no matter what district you
happen to be living in you can throw a
lot of wheat or whatever but but
livestock livestock there may be some
limitations on things like livestock and
there's also the and then we're talking
just now about zoning there's also other
regulatory issues such as site plan
review so that a municipality May
legitimately subject a some portions of
a farming operation to site plan review
such as a Farm Stand is it then unusual
for a town to prohibit things like
backyard chickens things like that or is
that fairly common well that that could
fall under livestock and so there are
communities that do limit the phenomenon
known as Urban chickens some limit just
roosters and allow the hens because for
obvious reasons roosters are noisy so
that is subject to limitations so what
you're saying representative Reed is we
need a filter for urban chicken we need
an urban chicken I would like an urban
chicken filter and in bees too thank you
continue please thanks
we're getting we're getting great ideas
I'm so glad we're doing these
pre-briefings
all right so uh we're gonna Focus here
today on five uh we think big findings
from the from the zoning Atlas And so
one of the the big findings is we wanted
to look at what land is available for
starter homes and in particular when we
think about a starter home uh for
ownership typically this is going to be
a detached single family home but it's
going to come with a small amount of
land because it's not going to be
affordable if you have a large parcel
say 50 acres and you're going to
subdivide that and build some
single-family homes on it they're not
going to be affordable if you can only
put 20 single-family homes on it as
opposed to you know 60 single-family
homes on it and so minimum lot size and
other density restrictions uh are a
significant factor in whether affordable
single-family homes are going to be
available
so here we have a map showing where
single-family homes are allowed on less
than an acre with less than 200 feet of
minimum Road Frontage
okay and what we see here is only about
16 of the buildable land area in New
Hampshire is available for that kind of
development so even if we exclude
conservation lands like the White
Mountain National Forest you see that
big gray area in the middle that's what
that is uh if we exclude lakes and water
bodies and wetlands over 10 acres in
sizes are non-buildable areas even if we
exclude them only 16 of the rest of the
areas available for small lot single
family so those are the orange places on
the map here and you see that actually a
few of the the cities do reasonably well
here Nashua Manchester Londonderry
um Dover Rochester
Somersworth and then a few highly rural
areas some without zoning in the kind of
Northwestern part of the state but
everywhere else you know my town of
Amherst for example there's no land
available for small Lots single family
finding number two uh we were sort of
surprised by this we found that two
families seems to be the most harshly
treated housing type in New Hampshire so
there's actually as we're going to see
even less land available for
um small lot to family than there is
either single family or five Family
actually
um structures so uh so we find here it's
about 11 of the land area is available
for duplexes
um with a a maximum density of of
greater than two units per acre
and so again this is a kind of a measure
of where you can find and are able to
build affordable two family sort of
naturally affordable two family
structures
we also found 70 jurisdictions where two
family is just not allowed at all by
right you might be able to do it with a
special permit but you can't do it by
right
representative
uh thank you again for taking my
question is that do you do you expect
that that's just it doesn't make any
sense right do you expect that that's
just pure like stigma around duplexes or
what do you think might be causing that
you know it's hard to speculate too much
but I think part of what's going on here
um as we're going to see with five
family being more available than two
families it probably has something to do
with the state's Workforce housing
statute it's the workforce housing
statute defines uh Workforce
multi-family as five units or more in a
structure that is Affordable and there's
a definition of affordability in there
um and so that has probably caused a lot
of communities to be a little bit more
tolerant of five family than they are of
two three and four family but even so it
is kind of interesting the other the
other feature of this is that two
families under state laws not allowed to
be subject to site plan review and it
could be that some communities think
that well with site plan review we can
have a public hearing there's some
discretion involved maybe we'll allow
something if site plan review is
available that we will not allow if it's
not available
again this is somewhat speculative but
that may be a reason why three and four
families are actually a little bit more
widely available than two family
representative Gibbs
thank you
um
I'm curious
um I I should mention I work for hype
for 29 years
um I'm curious why the definite and you
may know this or you may not but if you
do I'd be interested
um why these definition of Workforce
housing is five or more units
um normally the definition of
multi-family housing is four or more
units so do you know why in this case
it's five or more
that's it's hard to say I mean this was
enacted in I think 2008
um and so that probably there's
something about legislative intent there
that that I'm not privy to there is
there is history to this representative
Gibbs and
it was maintained at the time in 2008
that five units was the the minimum
number of units necessary for a
developer profitably to be able to
develop multi-family now the statutes
have two different definitions of in
effect multi-family the workforce
housing law says five or more the site
plan enabling statute says three or more
meaning that's the jurisdictional
threshold for planning Board review
uh so for a planning board to exercise
jurisdiction over something other than a
single family home as as Jason properly
said they cannot do site plan review on
a duplex they can do if they want to
site plan review on a three Plex or more
to meet the requirement of the workforce
housing law a municipality must allow
five unit structures somewhere it's in
some reasonable fashion
thank you
thank you both
okay so uh let's move now to uh five
plus family
and here we have a slightly different
map because it shows also where uh five
plus family is allowed only with
restrictions so either it must be
guaranteed affordable or it must be
elderly only housing and we see that for
instance I think that's Londonderry
there in yellow much of its territory is
is open to restricted
um five plus family
uh and so we see here that small lot 5
family is available on somewhat less
land than small lot single family was
and again this is defined as maximum
density of greater than two units per
acre
um but it is allowed on on more land
than the small Lot 2 family was
um and so uh overall I think the the
conclusion from from all three of these
findings is however that the vast
majority of land is not available for
um moderately dense housing of any type
uh so that's going to be over 80 percent
of the land areas not available for
small lot single family two family or
five family or anything in between
and with that I'll turn it over to you
Ben thanks
Jason present the the remaining two uh
findings that we have the and these just
bear in mind uh these are five findings
that we chose because they really
um uh struck us as being important uh
but this is very preliminary uh and
there's a lot more to learn about the
data that are available and will be
ourselves studying it and relying on
others to do the same finding number
four uh looks at a region of the state
and so this is Manchester and it's
surrounding seven communities and we
wanted to essentially zoom in on a a
portion of the state to do a more
in-depth analysis of this and to
demonstrate one of the really important
functions of the zoning Atlas and that
is it can be combined with other sets of
data
and so what we did here was we took the
data that are in the zoning Atlas and
combined it with data showing the
footprint of buildings
that is demonstrating that a property
has already been developed so while the
zoning Atlas itself might say that for
these eight communities Manchester and
its surrounding seven communities 21 of
the land is available for development in
fact a good portion of that has already
been developed
meaning when you combine these two data
sets the zoning Atlas and the the
footprint data that we had available to
us only 7.8 percent of the land area is
available for development
that means not a lot in these uh fairly
densely developed communities you know
Manchester Bedford would argue that it's
fairly built out Londonderry might also
there's opportunity there perhaps for
redevelopment of existing areas that
have places that already have
development but that's a lot tougher to
do
so let's go to the next one and the last
uh finding and this like the like
finding number four this this shows an
important utility of the zoning Atlas
the ability to combine different
attributes so what we did here looking
at accessory dwelling units
um and and looking at uh how
municipalities approach uh their legal
obligation under statutes to allow
accessory dwelling units but also in
some cases to impose restrictions which
they legally can do making it harder to
develop accessory dwelling units the
bright yellow color
shows those areas that where two parking
spaces are required for any accessory
developing unit no matter the size so
you could have a studio apartment where
really only one person possibly could
live without you know having to trample
over the other person they're not likely
to have two cars and yet the
municipality requires two parking spaces
or uh and so that's one attribute the
other is whether a public process is
required uh irrespective of the number
of parking spaces so these two things
merge together show those communities
where it is quite a bit more difficult
to build accessory dwelling units to get
a permit to do it and you see that
throughout the state that that's an
awful lot of the state's municipalities
that make it tough to develop accessory
dwelling units which is probably the
most innocuous way of increasing our
housing Supply so so to clarify
a municipality can require two spots on
any additional ad you build so it's only
one by right but
they're allowed to require up to two
spots in addition to the Adu a a
municipality may require and the law
calls for adequate parking what is
adequate is up to the municipality to
decide
and so the legislature defines adequate
parking for the purpose of an Adu unless
the unless the legislature intervened
and limited that Municipal Authority so
you see on this Madeline the the the the
pink colors
are those municipalities that require
more than two parking spaces for an
accessory dwelling unit
I won't call them out but
um you can see where they are and you
can compare on the map which communities
do that so for an accessory apartment
that may be a studio the municipality
might require three parking spaces or
four parking spaces because they deem
that to be
adequate
let's move on now to our implications
and impact oh
Mr chairman a question uh
okay representative Gibbs oh thank you
um has anyone ever uh tried challenging
that in court
um that requiring two or three or four
parking spaces as adequate parking
um is essentially a violation of the
common sense definition of the term
adequate in the statute
uh as far as I'm no as far as I know
Representative no one has yet challenged
uh that sort of requirement
but it may be it may be um ripe for a
challenge
uh we want to move on to the uh
implications and the impact of the atlas
um and first off uh
the zoning Atlas itself is agnostic it
doesn't make judgments it simply
provides data
in an effort to provide folks with the
information available to answer
questions so first off what is it that
people need to know about zoning
what is its impact on development and in
particular and this is what really drove
this team to develop the zoning Atlas
what is the relationship between zoning
and Housing Development
uh it doesn't doesn't judge it doesn't
provide necessarily the answers but it
provides the tools to people who have
the questions to get the answers
and then really backing up what is what
is the purpose of zoning
anyway you know if you go back we've had
zoning in New Hampshire for now almost
100 years
it's in the mid-1920s when the
legislature passed uh it's a a form of
what was then called the the standard
State zoning enabling act which was a a
model that was promulgated by the
federal government under the the U.S
Department of Commerce uh in the in the
20s New Hampshire adopted a late draft
of that in I think 1925.
and that was that uh in the city of
Manchester adopted zoning under that and
that was upheld by the New Hampshire
Supreme Court as a legitimate exercise
of what is known as the police power
that is to protect public health safety
and Welfare
that is the essence of the police power
and this is a power that is uh inherent
in the legislature and given two
municipalities through acts that you
adopt
um over time
uh the interpretation of what zoning is
for has dramatically expanded and I
would say in some cases has been
contorted
so in the 70s and 80s we had a real
really boom booming time for development
and population growth uh and we see a
response to that among municipalities to
say no we don't want to grow anymore to
dramatically limit any kind of
development except uh in some cases a
single-family large lot development
and the fruits of that you see now in
the maps we just showed what is the
ability of anyone in any Community to
develop a small home on a small lot it
is dramatically constrained you can't
build starter homes in New Hampshire for
the most part
representative Reed
thank you I just want to tell you what
I'm hearing and see if I am in fact
hearing you correctly so you're saying
that even the variability for a
municipality to have zoning was approved
originally for the health safety and
Welfare of people and now over the last
hundred years we've seen that not just
move Beyond well outside of that scope
of health safety and Welfare but
actually working actively against the
health safety and Welfare of people
I think you can make that argument uh
there are many communities in New
Hampshire and throughout the country
frankly that use Zoning for the purpose
of exclusion
whether it is based on fear of change or
fear of people who are different from
them or fear of development generally it
is it is uh something that
municipalities have done whether
consciously or not
and I would say over the past couple
decades have become increasingly
sophisticated at doing it so it's harder
to challenge these sorts of things in
court
um yeah I know I've already said this is
a state delegated power and you the
legislature have the ability then to say
how that power is used you're giving
municipalities this Authority
you have the authority to say yes but
and a couple of those circumstances are
the accessory dwelling unit law it is a
state law zoning mandate you require
municipalities to allow at least one
attached accessory dwelling unit
wherever a single-family home is allowed
uh but
there's flexibility in that law we
talked about the parking requirements
there's other points of flexibility in
what the legislature adopted in 2016 and
there are a good number of
municipalities that use that flexibility
to the max
to limit Property Owners ability to
build accessory dwelling units they make
it very difficult practically and
feasible
a second instance of where you the
legislature have told municipalities
yes you can Zone but is the workforce
housing law adopted by the legislature
in 2008
it requires that the basic requirement
is that municipalities must allow
through their zoning ordinances if they
choose to have one
they must allow a reasonable and
realistic opportunity for the
development of Workforce housing
generally speaking
part of that is that municipalities must
allow as I said earlier in some place
within their municipalities in a
reasonable Place
multi-unit structures of five five units
or more
they have to do that
and so as as Jason pointed out with the
the the comparison of the duplexes
versus the five flexes because
municipalities have been required to
meet this requirement of of allowing for
five Plex units somewhere it may be
easier to develop a five unit structure
in that town
that I duplex
and that just doesn't make sense
uh so and this represents the fact that
some municipalities will do the
absolute minimum
even if it defies logic
because that's what the law tells them
to do and that's all they're going to do
so where does this lead us
I can represent four questions thank you
along the lines of Workforce housing uh
is there a formula a percentage formula
based on population there is no formula
uh representative and this there is a a
really strong legislative history on
this that goes back to before uh the
year in which the workforce housing law
was adopted goes back
well in 2003 Senate Bill 95 passed the
Senate wound up in the house uh got uh
retained by the house Municipal and
County government committee and then in
uh 20 in 2004 and January ultimately the
the bill died but there was a lot of
consideration in those two years of what
sorts of requirements might be imposed
by the legislature or are there safe
harbors for certain municipalities that
are doing certain things and in the end
the legislature said no to all of that
come up to 2008 and what the legislature
did was look at a much simpler much more
streamlined approach to this
consideration
that does not look at mathematical
formulas uh does not look at uh you know
what proportion a municipality must have
based on population or school children
or whatever measure you want to come up
with they simply said you you they the
legislature said that municipalities
must provide their fair share of a
Region's need leaving it up to the
municipality to figure out what the fair
share is right now
the regional planning commissions are
working on those Regional Housing needs
assessments which I think for the most
part will have some sort of
recommended fair share allocation
so is there any teeth behind that at all
it's just a recommendation from the
regional planning commissions or well I
I think they're
it's not uh it's not they're not
required to do that by law so it is
purely a recommendation I think it would
have some weight in litigation but a
developer could propose their own
analysis that might be contrary to what
a regional plan commission would propose
okay
thank you
so
um where were we okay so
um room for change there's opportunity
here and the zoning Atlas provides a lot
of uh the capacity to analyze uh what
what we might seek to do
one thing is we don't need to flood our
communities with new housing but there
is opportunity for modest increases in
housing construction that would be
facilitated by Modest changes
to the regulatory structure in
particular zoning
I think we we acknowledge uh that zoning
barriers in particular impede economic
growth Statewide because it the
limitations on housing means that people
can't move to New Hampshire to take jobs
ask any employer I was talking this
morning with Steve Anin who's the
president of the New Hampshire Hospital
Association and he said every hospital
is desperate for workers I think it's
Dartmouth Health has a thousand openings
thousand openings that they can't fill
and part of the reason is
there's not enough housing even though
places like Lebanon are really doing a
good job in permitting new housing
Construction
more needs to be done not just by the
lebanons of the world but by the other
communities around them too
so the zoning Atlas data shows that
there's a lot that can be done
in our communities to make them more
welcoming to housing and that's the
bottom line and you
the legislature
have the power to help that along
so with that
um we have a little bit of a
demonstration for you um
two things to show you uh the first is
the Atlas itself so if you give me one
moment
um I'd actually just go directly to the
link
so I'm going to reload this as it
one moment the internet seems to have
failed this again
so the atlas itself will be available
for the public and I'm just going to
show you what it looks like so when they
first appear there's a pop-up box that
gives them some basic instructions about
how to use the atlas which I'm not going
to go through because I'm going to
explain that verbally so uh the initial
view is of the entire State and it's
color coded by um
uh the type of use so you have primarily
residential as Jason had mentioned which
is colored in Orange you have mixed with
residential so some residential can be
built but perhaps it's commercial and
also industrial or something like that
and then you have non-residential which
is purple those would be conservation
um
and Commercial and Industrial
and then of course you have the gray
area uh which is um sort of permanent
conservation or Wetlands or water
bottles
so um what can be done with this let's
see let me see if I can
uh so you see on the top on the left you
can toggle uh for one family two family
three family four family or five family
so for example at the state level
without getting into districts or
jurisdictions we can toggle five family
and you can suddenly see now
um that the orange areas are a very
small percentage of the state where five
family are permitted
also down at the bottom you can
toggle for
multi-family that's age restricted and
you'll see that there's some communities
in New Hampshire that do allow
multi-families but they're restricted to
uh to elderly
um and for some reason it's not showing
off here but the very bottom is
Workforce housing uh multi-family and
you'll see that there is one area of
here in the Hanover area
Hancock area that allows multi-family
but only
um
Workforce housing
so maybe I should zoom out here now
we'll do it thank you thank you Jason
I got it
thank you yes
we've just learned how to use this this
week so thank you there you go so um
also uh what we can do so let me just uh
refresh here
uh you can
um
okay you can
um look for a lot size so if we were to
put in for example
um small lot so let's say 0 to 1 acre
and apply that we can see again how very
smooth very few
areas of the state permit small lot
single-family homes
and just to play with this a little bit
let's see how many how much requires a
minimum of five acres
for a single family home so let's just
say five to one hundred so you have to
have a minimum five and there's actually
some areas of the state that say that
you need five acres in order to build a
single family home
and let's just play with this a little
bit and say 20 acres for a single family
home just for for fun here hold on
I can't imagine there might be any areas
of state that do that let's take a peek
and lo and behold
there are some areas that require 20
acres for a single family home
well let's click on the district here
and I don't want to call out any
communities publicly but
there you have it um
so okay so that that's another use of
this map that is available
now we could also go to
we can also go to individual
jurisdictions and districts and see what
the uh the attributes are so
um you can do that in a number of ways
you can do it by clicking on the map or
you can actually use the search function
here so let's take for example just
Groton New Hampshire
see
and so it takes us to that District we
can move this box a little bit out of
the way
and we can we can click on Groton and
get its um
there we go so now you begin to see the
attributes of the um of the jurisdiction
so Groton we see that 53 percent is uh
primarily residential uh 15 uh mixed use
there's a 32 non-buildable area it gives
you the percentage um of the
jurisdiction where housing is permitted
of different types so 68 for one family
68 for two family and it looks from this
that three four and five family are not
permitted
um
do you want me to put hooks okay
okay
um
all right so let's uh let's do this here
type in a book set because I can't just
locate it
okay let's see um so here we have
Hooksett
let me get rid of the search here
one second I'm still learning how to use
this why is this not showing up Jesus
uh
let me do that one more time
okay
so when I click that office
let me let me reload it so much no no
you're not you're not I should know how
to do this let me let me just start from
the beginning
we can we can do this
Street specific or just a town okay here
we go all right so now we can see the um
what am I doing wrong here Jason
then you gotta click on the map itself
okay here we go all right so we can see
now uh the um features of Hooksett
let's see 34 primarily residential 26
mixed used 11 commercial slash
industrial there's 30 which is not
buildable and then we can go into some
further detail and we can see that uh
single families allowed
um two families allowed slash
conditional let's go into the district
oh okay okay all right so
go back there and then you can scroll
down there we go there you go
thank you so one family is 59
um is allowed on
two family or duplexes is allowed in 21
uh three four and five family are are
allowed on 20 now you can go that's
jurisdiction and information but you can
also go to in
individual yeah
please
remember
so
sorry
I was talking about you we had a
conversation at lunch I got to give
representative uh Walsh some credit
that's okay so and then if you click on
an individual District within the
jurisdiction for example we're in
Hooksett District labeled medium density
residential we can see uh particular
details of that District
um and that includes the trans the
housing treatment but also if you scroll
down all the attributes that Jason had
mentioned earlier for example in this
District the minimum lot for a single
family is 1.13 Acres
um and then there's uh nuances of ideal
conditions and less than ideal
conditions do you want to explain what
those are sure so in in some districts
the minimum lot size and minimum
Frontage and maximum density for
multi-family will vary depending on
whether the lot has access to Water and
Sewer or if it doesn't depending on the
soil conditions and so we what we've
done is we the the minimum lot size that
we've been using in these Maps is sort
of the average over all those conditions
but we also show in there what the
minimum lot size would be under ideal
conditions say hooked up to water and
sewer and under worse conditions so not
hooked up to water and sewer and bad
soils
so um all those different attributes
including
um the maximum lot coverage the
maximum height and so on and all of
those attributes are uh included in this
information in the district so so those
are this is information you can access
at the district level but you can again
zoom out and get information about the
jurisdiction or even the state so the
atlas is hopefully um going to be a
great resource for people to use to get
information about their own communities
their own District but also for the
state as a whole
so the last thing I want to show you um
and I apologize that we fumbled with
this a little bit it's very fresh we'll
get better at it over the next month
um the last thing I'd like to show you
is
um the story map
so the public is going to
um
be introduced to the atlas that
interactive Atlas in a way that's
accessible for them
so they will
um arrive at a web page on the Saint
Anselm College Center for ethics website
that I'll be uh an introduction to New
Hampshire zoning Outlets
and
once there they'll be given some basic
information about the atlas and then
prompted
to access the story map
which is loading one moment
and the story map is going to introduce
them to what the atlas is how to use the
atlas and some of those static maps that
we've shown you
um in the findings and for some reason
it's taking a moment to load up
um
here we go okay so this story map here
I'll just just give you a brief
review of it
um it has a welcome and an introduction
to what the story what the atlas is
gives a little bit of a background on it
um talks a little bit about the
methodology of how the atlas was
developed
then presents some of the Statewide
findings that we shared with you earlier
about single-family housing five five
family
small lot single family
we're going to be adding some photos to
this over the next week or two
the adus that we've shown you
then there's some additional findings
which um if people want they could go
into by toggling to the right so there's
more information about small Lot 2
family
small lot three family four family and
five family
uh in addition there's some information
about parking requirements for five
family units and then there's that build
out analysis if you will for Manchester
and the surrounding communities that we
discussed with you including single
family potential in those communities
and small Lots single family potential
and then it'll introduce them to the
interactive Atlas as well as conclusions
and next steps
so when they arrive at the um that
landing page for the atlas they'll be
able to welcome to
um access destroying that and get the
understanding of the atlas there or they
can click directly on the atlas if they
feel comfortable already and uh and
interact with it there'll be additional
resources there Jason is written a
written a methodology paper that
explains in great detail how this Atlas
was generated for those who really want
to get into the weeds there'll be some
links to our national Partners the full
data set in CSV file will be available
for researchers to download in the end
we hope that this tool is available and
made use of by um by everyone in New
Hampshire by by members of the public by
researchers trying to understand how
zoning impacts our communities by policy
makers who are trying to understand what
we can do with the community or at the
state level to adjust our zoning to make
it more welcoming in our communities for
housing
and and Advocates uh and in the end we'd
like to have a healthy discourse about
what's happening in our state around
zoning so thank you for uh for having us
today well I I just I want to thank you
for all the three of you and then the
rest of you for coming up with this I
think this contribution to New Hampshire
is incredible uh makes me proud to be a
saint A's Hawk to have this kind of
research coming out of CNAs
um really proud so
um thank you and I'm looking forward to
looking at Goffstown specific but what
are the questions that we have I'll
start with representative Walsh thank
you Mr chair and that was May 9th you
said it's available to everybody yes
okay
um and I've got a question that's
probably not related to this so I'll
wait till the end
representative Damon
um I'm representative hope Damon
Sullivan County District eight so I have
Claremont and Sunapee they're like very
very different and seven other towns
so my question to any of you is
could you note
say the top three things you think
legislature should be addressing to move
us towards that modest increase in
housing production just a little
question
let Ben handle it that's a great
I think I'll be very general in giving
you the top three uh because there's so
much that could be done
um I think
affecting
uh process at the local level
is an important measure the legislature
can can work on that is making it easier
to for
easier more streamlined fewer barriers
for someone to get through an
application process now some of this was
done by the legislature of last year in
House Bill 1661 that's the that was a
compromise Omnibus Bill that had added
to it was called the community toolbox
bill which had been in Senate Bill 400
and it took a lot of the provisions
there
and there are some measures in the
legislature right now in this session
that I think are worthy of your
attention one is the um
house the housing Champion designation
program which is a Senate bill it's past
the Senate and has then been tabled for
the the Senate to add to the budget uh
that was something that was part of the
uh Community toolbox bill that was uh
frankly left on The Cutting Room floor
of House Bill 1661 but it's a it's a
really good idea it's a voluntary uh
program for municipalities to opt into
that would
indicate that they are the doors are
open in the community
and
so that that's basically two different
sorts of things
um
I think
the legislature should look at the sorts
of things that I characterized as
mandates uh you you have already done
this with the workforce housing law and
with the um the accessory dwelling unit
law uh and so you have done this before
I think there I think you should
entertain additional
possibilities for requirements of
municipalities and part of that might be
process part of that might be numerical
standards you know dealing with
thresholds of jurisdiction for site plan
review or how they how municipalities
regulate uh multi multi-unit
developments
uh and then finally uh probably be on
three now
um there's there's funding
um you know uh so I I work for New
Hampshire housing we administer on on
the let on the state's behalf the uh
affordable housing fund uh they're
they're in the current budget before the
house actually going be going to the
floor of the house uh next week uh there
is a 15 million dollar appropriation to
the affordable housing fund a 15 million
dollar appropriation to invest in H
uh there are other things that didn't
make it through uh house finance that
are nonetheless worthy and I think
division one acknowledged that uh that
these were things that were were worthy
but
um you know
house finance committee was they had
certain numbers that they had to meet
and division three was uh consuming a
lot of that
and I think that this will come out of
course in negotiations between you and
the Senate so those are things that you
could do this year and next and there
are probably a lot of other things too
thank you Ben
thank you uh representative oh
Jason
hey
thank you Mr chair uh I I just have uh
two recommendations to add to that list
I was interested to read the Mercedes
paper this morning about adus and I do
have some findings about that about uh
how much of our land area is available
for we could call it California style
adus so these would be districts where
um attached adus are allowed by right
without a special permit a public
hearing process
where detached adus are allowed in some
fashion
where no more than one parking space is
required for an attached Adu
and where there's no owner occupancy
requirement and where the attached Adu
may be larger than the state minimum of
750 square feet
and or the state cap on how
our minimum on the cap of Municipal
regulation and I found that only 11
percent of the state land area was
available for adus meaning all those
features so that seems like an area
where
the the state statute could be amended
to encourage further Adu development and
then we also don't have in the zoning
Atlas because these data are already
available a catalog of town wide
Provisions
um the state OPD already has this
through their Municipal survey but the
state does authorize municipalities to
have just a hard cap on building permits
and even just have a complete moratorium
on building permits for one year and
some communities do have just a hard cap
on on how many housing building permits
can be issued in a year which seems like
the the most stringent possible
regulation that you can have
representative
thank you
so I understand that this Atlas is kind
of part of a larger Atlas plan and
Nationwide Atlas plan and I'm wondering
um if all of the data points that you
collected are the same data points that
the other atlases are correct collecting
and if you did not collect some that
others are collecting and why
and
um so that we can compare against each
other and then also
um
is this project kind of a one-off or is
there a hope of renewing this data or
um let's say hypothetically I was
interested in every time that my
municipality changed its zoning to ping
you and be like hey now you want to
update mine
um
would is that a feature that's uh going
to be live on the website that's
or how would someone uh go go about
giving you that information if you are
the ones that going to be managing it
long term
so I I excellent question I I can't
speak for the national zoning Atlas team
but I think what you said is exactly
what they're thinking the envisioning
that by having an atlas like this at
every state well researchers and policy
makers will be able to compare States
and regulations to help understand uh
what kind of zoning and land ordinances
work and help communities flourish and
which ones are perhaps more damaging and
destructive so
there may be other purposes to that
National Atlas but that's one thing I
think could be very clear as far as um
the stewardship of this Atlas uh So the
plan is for the center for ethics and
Society in partnership with New
Hampshire Housing and the office of
Planning and Development to maintain
this Atlas and refresh it year after
year with a team of student interns and
capable planners and people who
understand land use ordinances so that
it's uh it's a constantly accurate tool
for our communities to use and
researchers to use to help understand
zoning in New Hampshire so yes an answer
to your question we welcome
communities and people who see any
changes in their zoning or maybe errors
in our current data to to reach out to
us we have we'll have an email address
that's promulgated to send us those
Corrections we'll have our researchers
double check to make sure that it's
accurate and then I will make those
changes so yes actually we're going to
be very open uh to to those kinds of
um
changes in improvements so
follow up
I since since it's going to be an Ever
um changing uh
uh data set
um I guess my question is you also are
allowing the download of the data set so
are you also going to be like doing like
snapshot kind of downloads of data sets
so that you can compare year over year
or you know all of the or you know
decade over decade and what policies may
have been successful or not
right and thank you representative
that's that's correct we what we want to
do is have waves of the atlas so that we
can compare communities at the same time
slice that's important for researchers
and it's important to give an accurate
picture when we're comparing communities
to each other
um so that you know we know okay this
change happened then and then we can
observe perhaps what the effects of that
change are on say housing production and
affordability
as far as the
um the fields that we have I think we'd
like to think that we've raised the bar
with with with our Atlas because we have
added new Fields uh things that are
relevant to New Hampshire we have
everything that the other atlases have
and then some we've added manufactured
housing minimum frontages a number of
other things so
um we hope that this kind of uh raises
the standard for atlases that come after
I took a research method class at Saint
Anselm College and I can't imagine like
this would be so cool to look at like
longitudinal over certain number of
years um I have a question about how
um the New Hampshire zoning laws
compared to other states and have you
had an opportunity to look at maybe a
community the size of Goffstown but in
um
like somewhere in the midwest or
somewhere on the west coast and and how
are those zoning ordinances different
that's I mean I mean there's so much to
look at right
I know much more about New Hampshire
than other states but I have looked a
little bit about at some of these other
places uh through the Connecticut Atlas
and I've followed some of the state
level reforms that have happened in
California zoning is so different state
to state the terms are different the uh
the ways that they they regulate
um housing production are are pretty
different
um there are some constants uh minimum
lot size is something that almost every
jurisdiction regulates even Houston
actually technically regulates minimum
lot size even though they don't have
zoning
um you know looking at different
treatments for the number of units in a
structure that is something that is is
fairly constant I will say that in more
urban States you often have zoning
Provisions that are specific to areas
with Transit so we don't have that in
New Hampshire but in Connecticut that's
that's important and in New York I'm
sure it is as well well
in general uh the the studies that I've
seen do show that that New Hampshire has
fairly strict regulations compared to
other states especially in terms of
things like lot size and maximum density
restrictions and in much of the Midwest
and the South and the Mountain West
density is regulated a lot less
I I just add to this I think there are
also different layers of government in
different uh portions of the country so
in in New Hampshire New England frankly
uh County government really does not
have a land use regulatory role whereas
it does in most of the rest of the
country I I started as a planner in New
York state working for a County Planning
department and we had actual regulatory
authority over and in addition to what
the municipalities had and the village
districts
um so I I think that they're they're
difficult to compare and I would
contrast zoning from other types of laws
so you're as legislators you're familiar
with the idea of uniform laws and so
there's a you know a councils who
develop uniform codes the building code
is one of them but then on Estates and
divorce law and custody covering a wide
range range of laws and so there is an
attempt nationally to seek uniformity in
many laws
zoning is just the opposite it started
from a uniform place in the 1920s and
has radically diverged from state to
state uh since that time and I I see no
Prospect of bringing them together at
any time
even within the state there are some
really unusual cases perhaps the most
unusual zoning ordinance I found in in
New Hampshire was in Whitefield where
every development gets scored according
to a number of points uh if it has
attractive features that benefit the
town that's how it's supposed to work
and and if you score enough points it's
allowed by right if you don't it's a
public hearing and if you don't have
enough for that it's it's prohibited so
it's very unusual way of regulating
zoning so there's really no template out
there
thank you representative McConkey
thank you Mr chairman and I'm not asking
you to bring your screen back on here a
question where possible do you identify
Parcels on there because I believe you
said that there was there was a street
lookup feature and for those towns that
have GIS or the state has already done
GIS will you pull out parcels
that's a good question I I think with
the interactive Atlas you can get a
street address
um and find out what the zoning features
are there and it's easy to connect the
the zoning Atlas to the Statewide parcel
layer we don't provide that right now as
a something that you can download that
would be a massive data set but you
could certainly do that we do want to
caution a little bit about the
resolution of our GIS
it's not down to the foot
it's probably not even down to to the 10
feet this there's a little bit of
ambiguity there sometimes about how
these zoning boundaries are drawn and so
in with any GIS layer you're going to
have a little bit of fuzziness in terms
of where exactly the boundaries are but
we we do expect that this will work at
the parcel level that you'll be able to
find a parcel and be able to to locate
that to a zoning District thank you
representative walls thank you and
thanks for taking my question and what
is the web address we will be able to
find this uh when it does go live yeah
oh that's a good question
um
New Hampshire NH zoning atlas.com will
direct you there it'll be a redirect to
the College website
but NH zoning atlas.com that'll be live
on the 9th and that'll be live on the
night and I'm sure
I think we're the first people to see it
we're still working out some of the
Kinks and there's some additional things
we're gonna add photos and things of
that sort of thing awesome pretty much
the main tool
yeah thanks Mr chair and uh thank you
thank you all again this isn't about the
atlas but I think Mr Frost might be able
to help me
um is there some data I know I've seen
it I just can't find it again on
percentages of increase in housing stock
town by town over the last 10 20 years
possibly oh sure can you can you tell me
where to get it or provide it to us or
not I it's probably easier for me to
provide you with a couple of different
sources one is uh the building permit
data that is compiled by the office of
Planning Development okay okay and then
there's housing stock is building
permits don't necessarily translate to
things that get built right
um because you know not every building
permit results in construction but it's
a good proxy uh and then there's also
the American Community survey which has
actual housing stock data which can be
taken down to the municipal level and we
can get that for you
thank you very much
representative Reed thank you and I just
had I had some logistical questions I
think you've mostly answered in terms of
zooming in and
um and providing the link to us I just
wanted to make sure that can you send uh
the committee your presentation for
today the slides and um would be very
grateful for that and then I had a
little bit of a disingenuous question
did I hear a few minutes ago you say
that towns are enabled to put a
moratorium on development unlike for
example not being enabled to maybe uh
put a moratorium on rent hikes
just
for what I heard
that that is correct representative
within limits
so there is
um a statute this is in RSA 674 I
believe it's RSA 67423 uh dealing with
growth management ordinances
uh and it it in fact that statute used
to or may have been 23A it used to call
it moratorium that was changed I think
in 2008 uh in a recodification of those
statutes
and the recodification
um attempted to embody the conclusions
of various decisions of the New
Hampshire supreme court regarding growth
management and I think what you have now
in statute is an accurate representation
of what the law is as understood by the
Supreme Court because there have been no
growth management cases litigated in New
Hampshire since that time so yes
but there are very tight constraints on
Municipal authority to impose moratoria
all right well thank you very much I
sincerely appreciate you coming
thank you thank you
all right so moving forward I was hoping
to have a meeting on the 14th but uh
representative Gibbs uh informed me that
the house Democrats will be having a
full day caucus is that correct okay so
um I will move forward I'm hoping to do
maybe the 21st is there any objection to
that Friday the 21st
from what I hear right here
okay so um representative breed I need
you to resend
oh wait I need you to re-coordinate
um the people that you would be having
it all right
okay
that sounds great so I'm hoping to have
at least an hour conversation about
possible solutions
um that we've come up with so far and
then any other stakeholders you'd like
to bring in
um and then we'll move forward from
there if that works so um save the 21st
in your calendar and we'll uh I'll be in
touch soon thanks everyone
everyone had summons